wow great mov everybody around the
world it is January
24th
2024 welcome back
everybody thanks for being here today we
have a phenomenal
episode that that is my guarantee to
you yeah and if you don't like it if you
don't like today's episode you can
charge back YouTube for the membership I
don't like it you always have that
option I mean it's kind of a risk-free
proposition if you want to try becoming
a
member come and then if you're not happy
with the membership you can charge back
YouTube I it's like a free
refund but we can't guarantee that do
you do that a lot we could try it no you
well you I don't know I think that they
would get the the money back most likely
I mean You' have to commit fraud but
it's like not that much money so I
thought it was free little bit little
bit of fraud it's l yeah I mean it's
it's no it's obviously fraud but it's
just not that much money I thought it
was free not much fraud yeah not that
much fraud it's a it's a a touch of
fraud that's not fraud my career a touch
of
fraud yeah anyway we have Jeff whitet
coming in to give me it's a long awaited
low tapered
F imagine if e got
[Applause]
[Music]
a wow okay um that's gorgeous my hair is
getting pretty long so Now's the Time a
lot of people were saying oh you said
you going to grow out your hair that's
true I did say that but I didn't foresee
the ninja of low tapered fade meme
happening and so I have to seize the
moment people
mhm yep I have to see this it's true so
also we are here to announce the long
awaited the highly anticipated
[Music]
the the tour day
Force this is the H3 Bachelor season 2
starring Jeff Whit he's coming in
everybody knows that Season Two Season
Two Season three I said you said two you
said two season three I said three in my
head in your out loud it was it was
different than I definitely was thinking
as I said it this is the third
one I can't always be you know I can't
predict what comes out of my mouth only
what's in my
brain this is the third season and the
first two seasons without overanalyzing
it resulted into two romantic uh
longlasting romantic partnership true uh
so I have no reason to believe that the
third one starring our dear friend Jeff
Whit would be any different at
all but we have so much to
discuss he's coming in at
2:00 and you know I'll be shmooing with
my
barber you know as you do as you
do so we got all kinds of fun stories to
get to though also we're going to burn
our Stanley Cups today there's no rain
there's no clouds there's lots of clouds
why are you lying it was not cloudy when
I outside sorry it's not
cloudy it's a pretty nice day
outside Dan is doubting my weather
credentials I am Mr weather it's a rainy
day out here in Los Angeles you forget
who I am Dan is walking to the window
can't seey he can't see the guy he says
bro it is not raining what pre chance of
precipitation zero 0% now 0 2 0 3 0 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12
0% 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 zero so we're going
to burn those [__]
today and I don't think they're going to
I don't think they're going to make it I
don't think either one of them's going
to make it burn burn and burn
so but we'll see it's going to be fun
also I learned about Stanley Cups
apparently they have lead in
them allegedly which makes it a perfect
compliment to G
fuel yep if you want
to insert lead into your
body a lead jly which is highly
unrecombined
[Music]
what is this thing someone did like a
lead swap test on it yeah and it tested
positive for lead hold on let me show it
and then um so let me show it and then
AB you can run D for Stanley
Cup
sure cuz I know you're a Stanley simp no
I know you got not at all I spent all
break talking [__] about it to my niece
oh for real I thought didn't you guys
buy one no this this was the one that I
have is my nieces it just didn't come in
time so we
another one for her oh okay okay Stanley
is leaded I'm going to also do a lead
check swab to see if it is bioavailable
which I expect it is it does have a bit
of glue over it so I cracked and cracked
and then I just slide
open ah sorry slide open the
sleeve learn more at leadsa
mama.com you think this lady's wrong
lead safe Mama no come on she seems I
will edit this pretty invested in
inad she doesn't seem very good at using
instrument I'm going to visit leadsom
time with me trying SL hard time with
this there we go there we go slide open
the sleeve and there's the yellow liquid
you put a little bit of the yellow
liquid on there and we rub it Stanley
Cup are you watching and if it turns
pink or red which it is turning pink
down in there it's already turning
turning pink and you can see it turning
pink here oh no um that means that the
lead is bioavailable lead safe mama.com
and if your child touched this that they
would be
getting that dust on their hands oh that
looks bad what we need to do is Advocate
that of straw hole I think she she
drilled a hole through the bottom to
test it it looks like she said that she
removed some
glue so this is this is the bottom so
she's done something she like popped it
open yeah yeah yeah I'm B which is a
fair test I mean I don't want lead in or
outside of my drinking bed I guess the
less lead the better you're right but if
it's
like embedded in it in a such a way that
it's not in any way interacting with the
water than right there's going to be
accidents where that brain blood barrier
breaks yeah that's true right happens
the Stanley brain barrier
so we prefer without lead here at
leaf.com that's true
she's she wants that lead
safe from Kitchen wear especially items
that might be used by a child there's no
excuse for there to be lead in an item
like this also I want you to know the
only uh test kits that are re re um
reasonable and um that work are the lead
checks they have a low threshold of
detection of 600 Parts million so that's
lead checks here is lead safe Mama I'm
just curious about her her mission
statement
now lead safe Mama's website menu button
click here okay let's click here this is
interesting it's just a button that says
click here all right let's do it usually
same website cuz you open Amazon and it
often times shows private
information yeah there was definitely
something up there oh is it logged into
something yeah I think it just Auto
detects is the thing even if you're not
logged in oh okay it showed an address
yeah
oh that's not good we got it though so
nice we have the button oh and
okay sorry everyone that was the button
that you just saw they think they'll
love the the the lead got us our uh
button screen was not activated so it
just showed a glitched out screen for uh
that oh okay well there it is I'm on
lead safe Mama's website she she's got
this great button here it says Le web
let safe Mama's website menu button we
click that and here it goes back here
I'm GNA so she has led safe Mama LLC
Amazon affiliate links I'm going to open
this um
Ian and then I'll zoom in I'm curious
what address did it
show this one is that what you were
saying yeah I can't see it from this
angle it's just a generic it just says
okay delivering to
Glendale and a zip code that's not ours
I mean it's not even close to us [__]
blend we don't live blend blend's a lame
I just saw I didn't know what was shown
and I hit the button no that's fair
that's good SC but this is interesting
she's saying the lead safe one this is
the one that I ride for is the Hydro
Flask oh so she's advocating you think
she's working for big Hydro Flask she's
this is an affiliate code oh yo for real
yeah it says so here she's she's up
front about oh she's corrupt you think
so clearly well she got to she's doing
the lead thing she got to make you know
what I mean she got
to for those those test strips yeah it's
an adree page Dan it says ad free same
thing we went through with Dr IDs and I
don't know I just feel like it it
muddies the waters I don't know if I can
believe lead safe Mama anymore Mama well
she's also testing here here's another
affiliate code to a lead safe Mama
affiliate link for the lead
detector glowing lead test kit wow she's
this she really is passionate about lead
wow you know would be funny if she
actually was the one eating lead cuz
she's like I'm passionate about it and I
put a little bit of my wine every night
it improves the flavor the Romans knew
that all different
flavors some people hyp um have
theorized that the fall of of Rome was
in part affected by their massive
amounts of lead consumption
yeah lost their minds over time more and
more does that have real historical like
do do historians back that or is that
more drink lead like they literally put
lead in their drink I am familiar with
as like a sweetener or something
sweetener they l
lead it's not hard to imagine that that
would have an impact it was a Highborn
Roman thing too so this should be
affecting the huh the congressman and
the Emperors and such Highborn Roman
sipped beverages cooked in lead vessels
and channeled spring water into their
homes through lead pipes some his well
that's just that's happening in uh Flint
right historically that's true Michigan
shout out some historians argue that
lead poisoning plagued the Roman Elite
with diseases such as gout and hasten
the Empire's fall well gout isn't going
to end the
Empire oh gout can be terrible though
but it's doesn't affect your mind it
just makes it just gives you lots of
pain in your joints right that's it can
be horrible yeah I mean that can be
debilitating true the fall of the great
Roman Empire minimizing if only lead
safe Mama was around then by the way
that's our mention of the Roman Empire
for the week
yep the week episod our first one
today all right so what so you have
something to argue against lead Mama AB
the other ones that people are not good
they don't work pleas don't they said uh
they responded because there was a bunch
of other Tik toks like this being put
out and it says uh in short yes Stanley
tumblers are sealed with a small trace
of lead in their uh insulated cups but
the lead is completely enclosed by
stainless steel and does not come in
contact with your drink unless it
breaks see that's not a comforting
that's not a comforting what if it
breaks in such a way like I feel like it
would have to be catastrophic damage for
it to break in such a way that it's
leaking out you and are you using the
Stanley Cup at that point well listen
somebody is going to be using that cup
they're expensive you drop it there's a
little ding yeah that leaks out a little
bit in the cup you're going to use it
you don't know there's Le in
there inside you know what I mean what
where we where where did we go wrong
just from the top go ahead a and then
also says as far as the accuracy of the
leg check test used on Tik Tok a report
from OSHA that dates back to 1994 states
that the FDA reported that the swabs
were able to detect the pres of absence
of lead and
96.6% of the pieces tested what is that
so you're saying that it's that it
wasn't even detected in 96% of the uh
the units they tested from
Osha Osha tested Stanley Cups yes and
96% tested negative correct well not L
mamas tell to bring out the whole ocean
tell them to break out the whole
lead uh well there it is okay Stanley
Cups apparently there's lead in them
which is funny cuz now I can say that
and it's not like defamation because
sure it's like negligible and it's
probably not in most of them as o said
apparently according to
OSHA but I can say there's lead in them
and and that's not
defamation yeah yeah there's lead in
Stanley cops evidently you want to go
burn one now [__] yeah dude let's let's
Freebase those fumes anyway that's
exciting so we're going to burn our
Stanley
[Music]
Cup um what else we got all kinds of
good
stuff let's start at the top though I
got to clarify some things see you next
Tuesday I had made a claim that caused
ruffled some feathers about that I was
going to start
dmca well what I said here is all
members content with peace and love will
be dmca Aid if you want to remove them
now with peace and love thank you thank
you thank you thank you so here's what
I'll say I'll further clarify it there
are some friends of the
show that make highlights for the
people and listen ideally it would be
nice if people
supported it'd be nice if everyone could
watch it right I'm making content if
people want to watch it they should be
able to whether they afford to or not
like the idea of of um uh money gating
it pay gating it uh you know it's it's
something that we don't generally ever
do even for our live
shows however I want to offer something
nice to our members
so you know it seems like after this
came out that most people are
comfortable with it being available to
anyone but I do want people to feel that
they're being uh compensated so here's
what we've done uh your concern is that
the paying members will feel slighted
yeah got it I guess there are some
people that pay for this and they say
well what's the point
right I see that's what that Reddit post
was on yeah
okay I mean it's yeah so anyway here's
what we're doing I had said previously
that you can clip our
podcast and I had even said that we you
can clip the members so here's what I'm
saying final
there's the clip you can clip the
members if it's reasonable length reup
full re-uploads will be
erased with dmca with peace and love
delete so no full re-uploads delete it's
an reasonably length highlight we will
let you
survive peace and love to that
otherwise on peace and love no don't say
that no peace and love to those who
fully
re-upload yeah so that's that you know I
don't
know um there was oh yeah the H3 podcast
well this one I'll be honest this one's
fair use I mean this is completely
transformative this guy the A3 podcast
he goes episode to episode and he cuts
out all the dead air and then makes that
an episode really Ric stuff here this is
from uh
Monday
yeah so this this is this is not my
content this is their content you know
what I mean this is pretty
amazing that
awesome J so here it is and how long is
this it's 3 minutes waa that's way less
than I thought me too yeah in a three
and a half hour episode there's only 3
minutes
ofy we be yapping dude I don't know if
he got all of them though but uh listen
you know how I feel about dead
air I fight it at every cost every
turn this is awesome though mhm yeah so
you know if people are if people are
jacking our our content and profiting
off
it you
know then then let's not do that okay if
it's a clip with the title and it's
contained and it's reasonable you're
fine kich there's the clip there's the
clip go look at the clip uh now there is
this one
clip in other news we always talk about
that this channel is a trend Center
seter we've done it all it happened Cody
Co bought a Gatsby did we watch that we
did yeah and it's like Oh e H3 podcast
already did that like two or three years
ago oh well I mean we've we've already
destroyed it yeah we're done with it
yeah I mean Bobby Lee crashed that [__]
head on wik feet people trying to do
that who's trying to do wik feet now
well Charlie said he was the king of wik
feed at one point have that
hole what an idiot it might be now since
you know but the thing I'm the god of
wik I was banished you understand like
I'm Lucifer like I'm the [__] demigod
of wik feed see a lot of people don't
like Ethan and that's totally fine you
shut up Charlie the god Los that's not
totally fine $28 what's totally fine
about people hating me yeah a lot for
some [__] especially with all this
anti-Semitism in the world Charlie it's
$7 a bag and that's still expensive but
then you also to in the bags aren't even
big to begin with it's 4 oz per bag o of
cookies for $7
especially when you compare it to
the thank you but then here's a new one
lonus Tech tips and these guys are at
The Cutting Edge the bleeding edge some
say of a technology M and here they are
say that some say the bloodiest some say
the bloodiest edge here they are he
thinks he's achieved Peak gamer form
he's look at this guy we are so past
this lus I could have warned you man
have fun with yourn back problem yeah
exactly so lonus got himself a scorpion
chair not only we got this thing like
three years ago we have worn it into
Oblivion and already thrown it up also
yep I mean I can't help but notice that
that's the three monitor model we we had
the
five dude who are these people they're
just stop trying minus this is the show
I love you man but we've got you beat on
Tech we've got you beat on feet we've
got you beat on mobility scooters
everybody just needs to Kiss the Ring y
go ahead y I'll
wait
yeah go
ahead we really are I mean pushing that
no we're
unbelievable so good so good luck out
there shout out to um lonus Tech tips
Shout Out woo big shout out that he
enjoys his new scorpion chair there uh
never before
soon do I think these people are ripping
us off no for the record I'm not
accusing them of that these are these
These are funny things that you know
float around the internet yo I don't
know if this is real but something in
the chat said Linus said Dan was just
being a
baby wait for real he's he's riding I
don't know if they're just kidding but
if he really said
that there's a d at his place too so may
was talking about hisan whoa oh that'd
be confusing maybe even if you did say
that Dan like there's a difference
between sitting in it in an afternoon
and sitting in it as a dedicated desk
for years a thousand per I mean get off
th% get off our nuts bro get off our
scorpion nuts yeah I don't know if they
have
nuts they must have some kind of
testicle how does scor
scorpions have
gonads they definitely do have balls
I've seen them uh let you've seen them I
don't know if they have ball no you they
have some kind of reproductive organ
though SE them mhm males have two grads
made of two cylindrical tubes they have
tubes they don't have balls they tubes
yeah love has seen
them they have goads Arisa put your
balls in my mouth get off okay oh you've
seen them too now get off our gonads
they're not balls they're cylinders get
off our
sindler get off
Myers [__] dude um also yeah so
this thank you
[Music]
Cav Cav we've talked about C Cav a lot
and there's a really fun update here
people were getting a lot of laughs you
know Cav Cav he's obsessed with his
Wikipedia page he getting old dude no
it's not it's still
funny it's still funny and I'm going to
keep talking about it he's obsessed with
his Wikipedia page and he's constantly
accusing
me of being behind some persistent
Shadow uh operation to deface his
Wikipedia page the th the thr goat thr
goat and I I keep trying to explain to
Ryan I literally I don't have the power
he says I want you to put the Wikipedia
page back to how it was I says Ryan I
would do that if we can make this all go
away I'll do that but I can't do that I
I don't I'm not
Wikipedia you know that's this [__]
guy you're asking me to break guy he's
asking me to break the the um editorial
credibility that uh is the backbone of
Wikipedia itself he called me Cav Cav
just not right also anybody can edit
Wikipedia why doesn't he just do it you
know why well he tried but he's so
incompetent he like got caught
immediately because his name is like I
am Ryan Kavanaugh 69 and it's just like
clearly that's you dude well there's a
lot of people trying to puff up his
piece now I'm not accusing him of hiring
people but I will say is that there's a
lot of people and I know that not a lot
of people care about Ryan so it is
interesting that there's so many people
trying to correct it but there is a
editorial standard and so if it's not
true if it's you know seems too puffy
then there are moderators who will come
in to protect the institution and uh do
what's right yep I I have no control
over them anyway the point is Cav Cav
he misses his old Wikipedia page so much
he started hosting his own fully blown
Wikipedia
knockoff hey suck D's ball it's
absolutely banana go further than
knockoff cuz like implies he like
changed a letter or something he he
cloned Wikipedia but it sounds like from
what here this is on his website Ryan
kavanau by the way since if you're
typing Ryan Kavanagh definitely click on
this does Ryan Kavanaugh look like
Harvey Weinstein wait where's our
website
what the
[__] what's going on here where's our
website's not even on the front page yo
hold
on what the [__] yo it was down for a
long time it's it was down
for yeah 35 hours it's still down here
it's just knocked down fell that far off
it was offline for a long time but that
wasn't because of the offline I saw the
dip and then it started going up again
but now it's hold on I can check
where is it I didn't even see it oh Bo
there it is oh it's so low wow below the
failure podcast which doesn't even exist
that does going on here what's happening
love this could be something nefarious
could be it could be it could be I'm not
saying it it is but could so what could
he what could somebody do not him
because I'm not accusing you could like
spam it with fake links to that website
to make Google see so there is some kind
of black hat oh but like I'm surely
competitors do that to each other all
the time Google's got to be smarter than
that I'm shaking right now average
position the LA let me see the last
seven days is 3.6 is the average Google
search position that's what I'm used to
seeing is three it's weird that I dipped
right now last updated 13 hours ago so
it could have happened something the
last just happened that's weird I I'll
keep monitoring but I think it will
bounce up I'm sure it's going to bounce
up especially if Google notices that a
lot of people are searching for it and
stuff like that click on it well I mean
dude historically if people type Ryan
Kavanaugh into their browser which I
recommend doing yeah and then they're
going to look for this page and they're
going to click this page I'll say I'm
not worried it's this happens sometimes
especially if the webite goes down for a
little bit it's going to bounce back up
okay okay good that scared me I mean we
put so much love and I mean was really a
public service does Ryan Cal I'll look
like Harvey Weinstein
Doom yeah it it'll it'll be back cuz the
website is back stronger than would it
ever beenin I don't think it can be
crashed again so make sure you go Google
it or if you're wondering about like the
question does Ryan cabin look like
over.com you should definitely name
these balls cuz it's too long to type
right into the address course Ryan
Google it or terrible URL yeah any I'm
going to actually you know what I'll do
I'll go to his website without typing it
in the search engine yeah if you want to
go exactly yeah if you want to go to his
website make sure you go to a direct ex
ryan.com no search required wait what
the [__] is this Z what what the hell is
his website he doesn't even have his own
name the
idiot is it R Cav or something well tell
me what the real one is so I don't have
to search
it so
anyway his website is also gone wait
what yeah it's super far down too
raven.com wait what what's happening
hold on I got to there's been a
Crackdown Ryan Kavanagh Google cracking
down on all Ryan Kavanaugh related
activities so number one's Wikipedia
number two is LinkedIn like BR please
nobody's going to his a LinkedIn over
our damn super informative Forbes that
Forbes article has not been there before
I think but that's interest so
hm Arc Kavanaugh wow see this is weird
but anyway if you go to his website
which I recommend just typing in if you
want to no you don't have to go there
I'll show you we'll show you don't go
there so it says blah blah blah here he
is with uh Kevin Cosner who I guarantee
he [__] probably either hates or
doesn't even know who he is
anymore the cost cost philanthropy you
really going to put that bro after what
you did where's his Wikipedia
page uh oh you click it so if you go on
his his
Ryan's official fact checked Wikipedia
page this is his official Wikipedia page
he wrote it like it's a joke uhhuh this
is our fact checked Wikipedia page you
click that does it go to wikipedia.com
no it looks like it this has got to be a
IP violation like big time like if
anybody works at Wikipedia or knows
anyone that works at Wikipedia you
should be aware that Ryan Kavanagh is
ripped off your IP cloned your website
to further his own business interest
this is additionally it's actually
against Google TOS to have duplicate
content on your website so oh is this
just a copy paste of like the if that's
the case it's absolutely against Google
think it is because as you can see it
looks exactly like Wikipedia to the
extent that at the top you have things
like view the edit like see at the
bottom view edit history and edit and
talk and when you click one of those if
you click like the talk page here yeah
click that look it links directly to the
actual you're you're back on Wikipedia
now oh that's so I think he literally
took a snapshot of his Wikipedia page
cloned it exactly with all the links
intact and then just took out all
negative mentions of him from the
article I'll tell you right now this is
something Google actually takes really
serious decep Searchers is one of the
worst things you can do when it comes to
SEO yeah not even SEO I mean if I was a
Wikipedia I wouldn't want somebody to
this this can't be the norm where people
just impersonate them and then do a fake
link this this is crazy this guy he
really thinks he can get away with
anything cuz he's Rich sorry buddy
that's just not how the world Works
you're 49 that's a rough 49 sorry I
scroll down I think he looks all right
for 49 yeah you're right I'm being I
scroll down to see the edits and I see
in the edits throst is in there wherever
that is because it's the real edit page
yeah when you go to edits you're you're
you're getting off of's website and
going oh I guess that one on his website
wait the edit page didn't redirect if
you go all the way down okay right there
you edit history on this page that that
one goes to Wikipedia there you go now
you're there you are Thro yesterday Thro
updated yest 23rd of January website
host a modified mirror also copy voil oh
he he's on it I think he's talking
about he's talking about uh the edited
or his mirror website wait how do you
know website post a modified mirror oh
[__] yeah he's he's referring to that
website I think so yeah if you click
talk at the top so he's been talking
about this before even us Thro is we're
always behind Thro thr is always 10
steps ahead Brian always goes you're
paying Thro let me tell you this Ryan I
if I knew who he was can I say I would
pay him but I'm not I'm not pay you
wouldn't pay him how about shake his
hand I'd shake his and say good work I
and I I'd pay him because I care about
the people that being said I have never
paid Thro I don't know who Thro is I
have never had any contact with Thro I
don't think have we don't never even
made an effort to contact Thro as far as
I'm no we've stayed far away from Thro
we don't we don't want mudy the waters
let's not Pierce
exactly is his own entity his or her we
don't even
know whoever you are Thro we love you
buddy so what am I looking at if you go
to the very bottom it says total page
you could page copyright the one hour
ago oh oh [__] there people are on it
what the [__] well this was posted like
yesterday on our subreddit so it makes
sense I guess okay maybe people starting
to look into it a little bit and I don't
know if thros is a member of the
community maybe it was forwarded him by
somebody um an edited version of this
article is being hosted on the subject's
ordinary website masquerading as the
real thing user contributions have been
copied as well as the talk page but all
criticism has been removed every attempt
has been made to mimic Wikipedia
including active links and Legal
Information at the bottom despite it
being a total misrepresentation of
copyright well okay this reply is from
Thro and they seem to they seem to know
the ins and outs of this so let's see
what they say I have removed the
template because it is technically
misplaced here while content on
Wikipedia can be copied modified and re
redistribute redistributed under the
same license there must always be at
least a link back to the original is
that right that's all so he can so
according to this he can clone it it
sounds like with with some caveats I
mean Wikipedia famously you know they
operate on this kind of like open source
license they're they're they're not
litigious about going after people
borrowing because I mean the whole thing
is like this collaborative kind of uh
project so it's understandable but it
sounds like there are conditions to that
which Ryan is not adhering to well I
understand like in the spirit of
camaraderie and uh knowled and stuff but
if you're using their name to give
yourself wrongful credibility right
that's a problem yeah they definitely
seems like and this [__] guy the
[__] guy oh this is so interesting
huh I'm telling you the Talk part of his
page is so interesting it's a war zone
in there it is man it is so
interesting let me see what else is
going on
there since we're here let's
see here's the
update this is from the 20th so it's
three days before no edit
summary merging category American
Independent Film Production this this
all just seems like standard kind of
cleanup stuff that's always this one
says bot I don't know what that yeah
beta Trappist the monk I don't what the
[__] is that mean updating LA Times
archived articles Thro is here last time
on the 24th of October first remember
too he says unsourced not mentioned in
body looks like he undid
something love that about him all
right so here it is so he's hosting his
own uh let me read this because this
guy's like a a web Tech I was watching
uh Ryan kavan part on the most recent
episode and I decided to open up his
personal website after AB mentioned it
what caught my attention was a part that
read check out Ryan kavan's official fat
checked Wikipedia
IIA when I saw next door uh what I saw
next shocked me he's got a whole ass
Wikipedia page about himself s hosted on
his own website figured Ethan would
probably get a kicked out of how
embarrassing that is you you
figured you were right
yeah
um if you pull up his official public
Wikipedia page and do a side-by-side
comparison with the self-hosted one you
can see how many of the sections have
been conveniently trimmed and
manipulated to make him look like a
great guy pretty funny thank you work as
a software developer and I comb through
HTML in the browser developer tools just
to see if I could glean anything from
the code doesn't seem like a simple Co
copy and paste which would be difficult
to fully keep function anyway as the CSS
style and class names vary quite a bit
the official wiip it he rebuilt it
yeah so this is like a serious project
by uh but then how did he still wind up
linking back to all of the original
stuff in there like if your whole goal
here is to kind of
like direct people away from your real
Wikipedia page which is extremely
embarrassing shouldn't you not link to
that thing that you're trying to bury
rep I believe he might be trying to
comply with their rules I guess maybe
mhm yeah yeah I think he just want to
take this when you search Ryan Kavina
Wikipedia on Google I think he just
wants the top result with his there's no
shot he's going to get it with this no
and it's a Wikipedia you can't beat them
yeah if you look in the code it's the
meta title the part that's going to show
up in Google search says Wikipedia
parenes fact checked official version
you ran you know that that looks sounds
fishy as hell yeah like nobody's
clicking that and thinking that's legit
man he's getting old dude s shut up Ryan
it's funny it's like typing in
parentheses super legit no
lies I show I show send a screenshot how
it looks in Google super funny oh yeah
let me see
um where oh here it is a little bit
Yeah so if you type it in send feedback
yeah I just figured also if you if you
want to send your feedback to Google but
you don't have to do oh no don't yeah I
mean if you I don't I don't have any
feedback okay well in that case but if
as a Searcher of course if you as a as a
patron of a search engine yeah wanted to
give what kind of feedback you even give
I didn't even know that button exists
well person my personally if I searched
Ry kavna Wikipedia for example yeah and
that came and I realized that his
website comes up I I'd say this is a
little bit weird right misleading
misleading maybe yeah yeah Wikipedia
fact checked official version Ryan Cavin
are we gonna add some more fact checks
let's let's keep it going Ryan yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay
uh he continued I'll finish this uh I
took an educated guess it appears to me
that Cav Cavs teams has at least used
some third party software to allow for
building Wikipedia pages on a personal
website or in the crazier case they paid
uh someone to build a custom web page
that matches the style and functionality
of
Wikipedia update on top of major
sections being missing when compared to
the official this also seems to be a
case of trademark infringement yeah well
I don't know I guess based on what we
read I don't I I don't
know but anyway we love him he's he's
he's he's advocating for
himself and that's what
anyone that's all we can do really at
the end of the day yeah self-love you're
right about
that lie cheat
steal got to love yourself yep not that
he's done any of that first rule of
being horrible you got to love yourself
absolutely I mean if you don't love
yourself who is going to if you're a
piece of [__] you know what I mean yeah
true
D Adele Adele thank you so much for the
fit and also thank you so much to
Francisco for 50 gifted Subs that's so
tremendous thank you so
much so
nice appreciate you guys so much for
that uh so that was a fun little thing
you
know also top of the show
here hour in top of the
show loves doppelganger we've talked
about him but this is getting weird this
dude and he's American I thought he must
be Swedish cuz he looks so much damn
like you yeah he's American as [__] it's
frightening it scares me so here here it
is he's doing a what is his name he's
movies are therapy he loves movies he
loves movies Man Loves
movies no no I love the movies kit kit
laser is his name hey guys kit hey guys
kit Laser All right so anyway here is
here he is have been announced Let's get
my thoughts and predictions on each
category a lot of people are making this
video right now you should watch this
one out of pity for best supporting
actor DiCaprio was not selected but
Sterling K Brown was and I'm happy to
see Mark Ruffalo in there we'll likely
see another win for Robert Downey Jr for
Oppenheimer costume design will probably
go to poor things and it's the first of
two times that Napoleon snuck in here
best makeup and hair will almost
certainly go to poor things best adapted
I wonder if him without the hat and
glasses would look the glasses yeah
probably not right we do seem to have
the same beard same glasses same mouth y
all same eyes do DNA [__] that's [__]
probably between poor things and
Oppenheimer I think Barbie's likely to
go home empty-handed mostly what do you
think about his analysis I'm not
listening okay yeah to be
honest and I honestly don't listen to
most of the videos I watch Oscars and
Oppenheimer I know they had that whole
first person he says Oppenheimer is
going to sweep maybe I don't know it's a
good movie five bagger you know I sent
it to my dad and he didn't think it
looked like me at all which is weird but
if you think it look yeah it doesn't
make any sense but my dad's like he's a
hawk yeah it's just do you not I was
trying to reason with him is like you
you got to see something it's like not
really I was like come on you're just
[__] he's the hawk he loves you he he
you know what I mean yeah yeah his your
face is imprinted on his brain of course
that's a little sus that he's saying it
doesn't look like you at all oh a
legitimate son maybe maybe maybe
brother wow oh yeah he's like I don't
know who that is was in another Nest you
know what I'm saying for [__] dude
for him to be that close I feel like
it's got to be my real brother half
brother no I'm saying real brother but
they like sent him separated at Birth a
twin he looks older
he's parat trap it's a parat trap style
situation oh my God so what happened
your parents just didn't want him yeah
yeah his name was hate they gave him
away [__] sent his ass to America
brother have we reached out to him cuz I
I want we got to do a DNA test it turns
out you both 100 100% yeah brother
brother we got to get him to try Kebab
Pizza yeah let's send him out to swe
yeah [__] the whole thing even if you
guys aren't related I feel like we could
spark a brotherly you could become Soul
Brothers yeah yeah I don't know about
that dress you guys up a matching outfit
seems nice yeah he seems nice yeah yeah
you don't have you're the only child
right I am the only child that's why I'm
kind of against this scary you know oh
no this is this is great your family's
growing man yeah the idea of having a
brother kind of Scar me you know he's an
older brother he's going to look out for
you that's nice give you good movie
recommendations oh yeah that's great
yeah um did we reach out to him yeah
we're we're talking to him oh we made
contact is he aware of love has he heard
this he said it's all the comments he
gets oh man wow do we know which state
he's located is he oh I haven't we
haven't gotten that for yeah well we can
certainly get him to call in I'm so
excited for this reunion I'm scared
brother we need to get Mory out here to
do a DNA test yeah oh my God maybe
that'd be a fun segment if he comes out
we can do like a Mory like yeah bring
Hawk back out yeah is Mor um is he still
doing his thing is he retired I don't
know like Mor might might be gone he
should be dead by now well he does like
a live if there if there's a God he
would be dead by now oh stop it m yeah
he retired in uh 2022 that's what I
thought hey there's an opening my friend
mhm gaping hole in the market for
exploiting family
drama essentially by doing parent tests
31 Seasons the longest running daytime
talk show with a single host in American
television history and I mean he started
at the beginning I remember cuz I used
to watch these when I get home from
school this was the type of [__] that
was on daytime Telly MH Jerry Springer
came and changed the game mhm before
that my was trying to have like a
somewhat legit talk
show after Jerry Springer came busted
the game wide open Murray became like a
straight up just DNA test every
episode every episode
right yeah he figured out good
content I mean [__] proof is in the
pudding how old is this
[__] I'm I believe that my also
Mor po am I confusing him with another
daytime I think he was a big uh
marijuana legalization Advocate he's 85
man Murray po Murray poic is 85 years
old that [__] was born in
1939 what yeah wow that was born before
the second world war for Christ sake
[__] his old D yeah ready to be
president okay I was right he has a he
has a weed strain named after him
then there's a video of him smoking it
what's it called the
DNA that's a good question I assume just
the Mory I guess the Povich Jerry died
at 79 see that's the thing it's not fair
Jerry died at 79 rest his soul uh but
Murray got to live to 85 why are you
knocking on on Murray so much you just
said yourself you would rush home to
watch him yeah but I was like I don't
know but you have to acknowledge that he
was a tremendous for Force for bad in
this world I feel like exploiting
people's pain and crushing one of the
most humiliating crushing moments of
their lives when they get exposed is and
then the the dad who's not the Dad
starts break dancing right the
father is brave maybe I'm being too
harsh on him I wish him a gentle
passing
Jesus I mean he's 85 he's not going to
live forever it was coming up I mean I'm
obsessed with that he was also he was
also a chain smoker for years so
that'll too so there you go he's beating
the odds I wish you a gentle fast I want
to find the name of
his of his weed strand though pick some
of that
up um there it is have we considered the
fact that he's evil my brother your
brother he doesn't seem evil that's what
I was saying his
name suspect that you may be the evil to
I'm love bro what the [__] yeah TR
that's what they that's how they get
youh they say the the the Antichrist
won't come they'll come before you with
like a smile and a suit mhm you know
what I mean he's not going to look like
the Devil he's going to be a
charmer that is what they say that is
true yeah I haven't thought of that
brother well we're going to have to do a
analysis my name backward is evil
love yeah I mean that is true not really
evil evil evil evil it is I know I've
known it all my
life well how about this my birthday is
June 25th Christmas is December 25th I
am literally the Antichrist birthday it
would be on June 25th oh it's negative
yeah it's six literally 6 months
opposite Jesus I supp Jen
suddenly
yo Mar is married to Connie Chung I
don't know who that is the
reporter and apparently the weed strain
is named does she Connie Chong Chief
let's go dude oh I didn't okay shout out
Connie she's out there
blazing oh shoot oh she's like 20 years
younger than him oh no uhoh problematic
age Gap she's 77 wait not 20 she's 77
bro no that's 10 that's 10 years I'm
off it's not 20 years it's less than 10
years actually nice math dummy you just
have it out for myy I don't know why
maybe he's a good guy I don't
[Music]
know but what whenever it is that you do
pass from this Earth and it will be
soon statistically
speaking um I hope it's I hope it's uh
surrounded by loved ones hope Connie's
there no Connie should didn't have to
see that I hope Connie no Connie do have
his wife yeah she should be there why
smoking The Strain together as I just
don't want that's that's so heavy for
Connie well she's coming right after him
she's not that young she
strong you're right you're right I
shouldn't underestimate her I mean she
was an anchor for NBC she's been she
knows she knows Zach I started to get H
some existential dread about
dying Welcome to my life I have never
really cared or thought about it but I I
don't know if I think it's part of
really Shredder passing yeah I mean I've
gone through phases of of thinking about
it but it's never like become a problem
where I'm just I can't stop thinking
about it or something yeah I uh I deal
with it on a weekly basis mortality and
things like that it's you know you got
to find good distractions that helps a
lot um but it it is terrifying yeah it's
good it's best to just what scares you
too much and ignore it um things that
are bothering you I'm not good with like
things that I can't control which is why
I'm not really good with doing drugs and
things like that um yeah the fact of not
being here what is it like what what is
that Darkness like can you even perceive
that Darkness you know what it's like it
was like it was before you were born and
I don't remember that and scares the
[__] out of me right um well how about
this this is something that kind of is
trippy every single how many people have
lived before us
Kings inventors scientists everybody
Napoleon all the [__] out there
he
swam who swam his ass SW everybody every
single one of them has died they've all
been through it right every single
person's got to deal with that
[__] right so I think you know I think
the comfort in that is trying to live
life to the fullest and you know when
you do pass on someone says like hey man
that that guy's a good guy I think that
is the the reward I'll say that about
you thank you appreciate that lots of
people will say that about you thank you
he's a good dude that's what the grave
will say I think ultimately I I do want
to have like an autobiography you know
Auto okay um that'd be my goal would you
say autobiography autobiography so that
means you write it about write yourself
yeah oh nobody's stopping you from doing
that that's true yeah that's fully in
your hands forward by Ethan Klein I'll
write a forward you write a forward for
his Auto yeah for for his AI Audi bio
yeah or autobiography or just biography
like someone else write it about me
that' be cool I mean autobiography is a
little does it more I guess it'd be fine
in your case yeah it's like historical
you know or if someone wants to write a
biography about me that'd be cool too
yeah that'd be cool you can't say that
Zach like it's okay to say like I want
to write an autobiography Jeff here but
like check my phone somebody should
write a biography about no they Lena I
think he's going to be here soon if you
want to a little self-centered I'm okay
with that I'm I want someone to write a
biography about me okay
well thank you so Jeff's arriving any
minute what if Ethan got a low taper
fade thank you for this you're welcome I
had fun making these two
[Music]
song O very moving dang it no
wow this is great this clip of Demi
Lavado from 2015 oh I have not seen
before and then I had a hard time the
rest of the weekend she says this is a
joke do we believe her no here and your
favorite dish is this before or after
the yogurt ruined her this is it before
it's before because it was after I'd
understand but
before anyway go ahead Demi and H your
favorite dish my favorite dish I like
mugs because they're very comfortable in
your hand and they hold the hot things
that you don't have to touch so um you
know coffee or hot
tea if she is joking props cuz that was
a very funny answer but here's here I'm
leaning no and if she's not that was a
very intelligent and wellth thought out
answer right yeah the alterntive she
just listed basically what a mug is I
mean what else does it do you know it's
got a handle and it holds hot stuff she
said for anybody who actually thinks I
misunderstood the favorite dish question
you clearly don't get my sense of humor
really girl okay was she joking about
the yogurt
too uh no she was very serious about
that by the way her we had a beef with
like her sister or something right yeah
yeah I like that was a very strange
episode we love the lavados and uh we
honor them I love mugs I like mugs if I
had to pick a favorite dish I'd probably
pick a mug
too I left that yogurt store and didn't
get the yogurt that I wanted I like mugs
bowls are nice you go with Bowl you
could go with a bowl I think bowl is
good
yeah Bowl might be goated like you could
eat anything out of a bowl right like a
plate if you have a plate plate is flat
and if you're trying to eat soup or
something you can't do that but if you
have something that you would normally
eat on a plate you could still put in a
bowl it might not fit well but it's not
going to fall out you can drink from a
bowl too like if you need one dish if
you're doing survival [__] and you have
one dish it's got to be a bowl I think
you're right absolutely I think the the
bowl is goated yeah she [__] up picked
the wrong dish
yeah if you need to do a bathroom you
can't piss on a plate you can piss in a
bowl you know well even yeah don't need
to piss in the bowl I mean well you're
talking survival you
know oh someone said re revel revel love
said that was poot not uh Demi
oh that makes sense I see James Charles
is still doing thirst traps this man is
[__] lost this is crazy dude
let's see what he's up
to that is some [__] some [__]
who's been following me for a while and
lives in your La let me
know quiet don't tell
anyone bro how are you mention it to
anybody our world is so sick that he's
still comfortable putting this [__] out
there
sister it's it's just absurd man yeah
really
sad really sad he's just solic in his
fans for sex
basically maybe it's for something other
than well with his
reputation why the why this whisper and
the don't tell anyone our little secret
our little secret don't tell
anyone also it's it's a story not a post
that's in the water maybe a little
bit well yeah the story well the stories
go away right yeah yeah
yeah that's a Snapchat thing right or is
that Instagram this is Tik Tok actually
oh it's Tik Tok they've all got it now
yeah there's stories on Tik toks yep
started on St our users attention span
isn't short enough I'm got to find a way
to find a way to boost those numbers
interestingly Dan I think you've you
find this interesting it used to be that
the videos were 7 seconds but the the
watch time on Tik Tok seems to have been
increasing quite a bit
we're moving in the other direction
minute we've discovered the glory of
content that allows itself to last for
long than 7 Seconds yeah I'm ready to
delete that [__] man I'm so over [__]
Tik Tok man I
was I was trying to warn you all I'm out
I'm like totally ready for the for the
government to ban them it sucks
dude I watch Instagram uh reals instead
yeah so I can see people getting hit in
like
yeah for for purpose of just like brain
dead content reals is way better also
you you'll see comments like a cringy
video on on Tik Tok like people comment
post this on Instagram reals for real
yeah because there's not much of a um
filter on there so the comments are just
absolutely deranged yeah and like I've
seen really disturbing stuff un reals
yeah no it's live leak it's like the
modern live really bad what is going on
with like Mr dude you know the guy who
they always trout out whenever
Instagram's in trouble or whatever like
he's always talking to you like this hey
what's up man know you're talking we're
buddies like that guy is always talking
about how like their number one priority
is like safety and the safety of our
users and fighting harassment and
bullying and it's like it is the worst
it's ever been it's so torit you are not
doing a good job you're talking about
this dork and I'm not complaining yeah
that dork yeah
watch like hey what's up
guys you know if he's Instagram
president he's just a a Zuckerberg like
Sian like there's no other way you get
that position unless you kiss the ring
yeah for sure and when I say Kiss the
Ring I don't mean just a ring I also
mean his booty ring hell yeah Kiss the
Ring not that
one that's
right never heard that I feel like
eating ass has got to be one of the
hardest things to force someone to
do man what an enlightened abot
take uh where are we so shout out James
Charles people I mean I don't know what
the [__] is wrong with the
world here's a clip of Ian Slater AKA
SpongeBob AKA home wer although no he's
not the home wer SL as
SP what I mean Ethan Slater Ethan Slater
Ian you're so good in that part yeah
walk that back I walk it back I walked
it back you are bullying
me no I'm not I am not
um I don't know why frankly it's so
viral just cuz he's so excited about it
I mean is this something that happened
recently or is this an old
clip I'm not sure exactly let me look
it's that spam a lot which that just
happened right well spam a lot is
running did it
close what's spam a lot spam lot
he is like currently in it
or relatively recent it's within the
last few months okay so here here's the
clip everybody's uh
analyzing filing wi it has been
unbelievable it's like uh it's it's this
like huge huge thing the Broadway show
is so huge and has been such a big part
of everyone's lives and then we've like
handled it with such love and care and
John Chu is like just has handled it
with such love and care I don't know
it's just been incredible and everyone
in it is I think everyone's just going
to like their minds are going to be
blown everybody who loves Wicked people
are coming to it for the first time so
he was in Wicked was he he was one of
the lollipop guys right no he plays Bach
who he wasn't a lollipop kid considered
a lollipop kid but if he were
in you could say he's a lollipop kid but
he's he's considered a munchkin he's
coined a munchkin oh I don't know I
don't know the politics in oz is
munchkin a derogatory word
uh not in written in Wicked it is a part
of that world I don't know about wizard
I think if you call a little person a
munchkin they'd probably be upset I
think so too munchkins are like a it's
like it's like Hobbit in Lord of the
Rings you know what I mean they're like
they're like a race in oz so is the word
munchkin from Wizard of Oz or does it
predate Wizard of Oz you know I don't
know cuz if it predates it then it's
derogatory in the see munchkin uh
mology they use that term munchkin for
uh food Donuts or there's munchkin
Donuts so does that got to go away it's
from the munchkins depicted as a race of
small childlike creatures in Frank bombs
The Wonderful Wizard Oz sounds like he
made it yeah he's good that's that's
pretty impressive by him yeah this uh
this interview took place the opening
night which was in
November okay so this is after he had
already divorced yes oh yeah okay but
everybody who who loves Wicked is going
to be really happy because these
characters are being handled with such
love and care I can't even express it I
I wish your wife was it's amazing it's
going to be really
special so wicked is a movie th this is
a movie that they made of the musical so
he's in the movie yeah with Selena with
Ariana Ariana or sorry close enough no
you're right
Ariana that's where they hooked up
that's where on the set of the movie in
London yeah she plays galinda who his
character is in love
with who's ginda is that the one that's
the good witch oh she's the nice witch
although it's wait until you see Wicked
before you call her the nice witch am I
right am I right it really humanizes The
Witches it's important for witch people
you're never going to look at Wizard of
Oz the same way you're never going to
look at a witch burning the witch you
know the era where we used to burn the
witch that era never really stopped with
all the anti-Semitism in the world is it
really time to start you know
whitewashing the black bring that up I'm
just saying it it's it's a problem Dan
right MH why you you know and and
frankly the fact that you're calling me
out is a problem I mean the J sh the
anti-Semitism the J shete thing the
other day it
seemed seemed like a little bit of a
stretch what that Double H Hitler
okay where are we so uh what's the
what's the fuss I I didn't I gen I don't
really what's the problem don't know
what the fuss is all about death the Jew
death to Israel excuse me Jes maybe wait
what did Ben say death to the Jews death
to Israel stop whoa can't say that
Ben what the
hell in the hell it's from fa how do you
say that faux
Moy
are you talking about D
is f MOA so this is like a gossip
Instagram page gossip Reddit he did say
love and care three times which I found
a bit oddd so I'm not trying to be mean
about his looks but this is truly
shocking me that this is what the guy
behind all this drama looks
like I didn't say that there was well I
mean that's right so is he like Mr
Broadway right now he's like a hot em I
mean yeah seems like it
doing spam a lot and [__]
single-handedly uh shattering the myth
that you need to be handsome to be a
star it's less the case nowadays I would
say also he's not he's not ugly he's
interesting looking he's interesting
looking yeah yeah yeah yeah like I
really do I'm no I'll get crucified if I
say that never mind say what you want
girl you think he's cute I don't think
he's cute I just look at him and I'm
like that's a I mean that's a
good-looking guy I don't
know he he's interesting looking yeah
he's interesting looking and he's really
talented however he's horrible so I
don't think he's hot at all but maybe
before this happened when he was in
SpongeBob I was like who's that actor
who's so talented who's nominated for
this Tony sure yeah but don't tell
anybody I said that do we know how tall
is he don't tell anyone can we F can we
check his height his height
absolutely Jeff is arriving
hey hi hey
Jeff is coming he's got all his barber
equipment he's got some sne what kind of
sneakers are those Nikes are those any
special type or not they Air Max
Jeff in China they look dope I just I
don't know much about
sneakers he's not miked but he's wearing
Nikes what do you see about his sneakers
Zach you're a sneaker head Jeff these
are the Silver Bullets Air Max oh so you
know they're the sil silver bullets Air
Max 90 Z assessing Jeff sneakers hold on
a sec here guys they're hype Zach
says would you have told him it's not
hype if it wasn't hype they're hype
those are yeah yeah um one second Ethan
I sent you something in Discord you turn
on the yeah as Jeff's getting ready guys
shout out to Teddy fresh coming out this
Friday at 10: a.m. PST we got this set
this set this blah yeah da da this one's
got the patches teddy bear patches uh
come on in yeah come come come join me
here thank you thanks for coming of
course
always yeah it's always good to be here
you know it's inspiring to come see this
place oh thank you I love when you say
that it's my favorite thing you want to
snack that thing you can but uh we
should just sit here quietly for 20
seconds so we don't anything soon yeah I
already used it we did use it today
already yeah whatever so what's the deal
we uh was this your idea to get this cut
or were you told by the audience uh no
this was my This Is My Idea trying to be
you been following the low tapered fade
ninja phenomenon look I got a lot of
stuff going on in my life right now it's
tough to follow you missed that uh yeah
I um I just got back from Mexico we
brought a bunch of drugs back cross the
war you got anything do you have
anything left over or not
no we had to destroy it okay we
destroyed it
all all right check with me after the
show no I'm look those days are behind
you know I'm a barber now and my
credentials you know people don't really
know that I'm a real Barber but I sent
you that picture just so you know I
posted it did you post it my insta
stories yeah I know you're a real Barber
yeah I created the poly D yeah you would
be nothing without you so let's let me
up dat you with the um the low tapered
fade meme so at least you know where
we're coming from uh can somebody link
me the yeah by the way for anyone who's
wondering Ethan Slater's 57 so putting
that out
there oh and by the way Dan I heard you
don't trust that I'm going to uh commit
to The
Bachelor he got he he got up is Dan out
of here but let's call him out I'm going
to call him out that after absolutely
call him
[Music]
out so go ahead go ahead
I'll wait for Dan okay so in the
meantime this is this guy's a twitch
streamer and he was just freestyle
singing and then he just brought out
this iconic line that's been heard
around the
world Imagine nin got a low
[Music]
F imagine if ninja got a
low so this was uh resonated with a lot
of people myself included yeah I see the
the meme potential of it yeah uh who's
he say ninja yeah ninja imagine if ninja
got a low taper fade yeah so now we're
intercepting that Meme and we're taking
it over that's Well he kind of I mean
it's more like picking up the crumbs
it's funny I remember when I had you on
the barber shop I wanted to give you a
cool haircut like this I suggested let's
do something cool and you wanted to do
that stupid double Mohawk from the wheel
spin thing you know and you said just
anything but a mullet which is what I
had at the time yeah so you were like
just you know I don't want what you have
just give me this dumb [__] and now you
want like an actual real [__] boy
haircut like this is so what well yeah
that was part of my thinking was last
time Jeff cut my hair we went silly so
this time let's go dope yeah we're going
dope [__] haircut the fade MH you say
mhm mhm no hesitation in like a good way
it's just a guy who cares about how he
looks man yeah you yeah so I guess
that's a [__] boy you know okay you take
care of yourself wear cologne I guess
that's like a [__] boy yeah that's
pretty lame can you smell me right now a
little bit yeah how do I smell good
thank you yeah [__] boy I'm a [__] boy
well we love that about you because this
is our future Bachelor ladies and
gentlemen and um the world is not ready
actually I'm not ready to be honest I'm
nervous
because your success rate is 100% And
when I said that I wanted to find love
it is something that I want to do
but am I prepared right now to like how
old are you I'm only 34 I'm not ready
for a relationship you only 34 you're
not that it's a meme that's like a m
that's what people say a kid he's just a
kid it's crazy you're not that young I'm
just kidding about that for but 34 okay
like I want I want to continue the H3
Bachelor success rate and that stresses
me out but I don't want to force myself
into a life with somebody that I'm not
happy with just for your guys' success
you know well unfortunately it is you're
going to have to marry the winner
there's no conversations about that
that's why I say I'm scared about it cuz
you know it's just a big commitment for
the rest of my life but I'm willing to
do it and I'm faithful that you guys are
going to pick great contestants I'm
hoping you got what did I what did I
request did I you want me to say what
you asked about your hyp itical yeah
Jeff had we were talking planning behind
the scenes me Sam and Jeff and Jeff we
were saying well let's get some
questions together oh yeah to screen the
girls yeah and Jeff had said the
hypothetical was something like we I
just found out that some dude uh
molested we're married we had a child I
find out somebody molested our child I
went and kill them I come back to the
house with blood all over my hands and I
give you the gun and I ask you to hide
it what yeah what do you do now my my
problem was that I think that's a layup
cuz if they molested your kid it's both
of our child then of course they're
going to hide the gun you know what I
mean yeah here's where this but now
you're an accomplice to murder well yeah
but what are you going to do yeah I go
to jail together the thing is when
someone molested your kid and then you
kill him I feel like they usually get
like a pretty light sentence slap on the
wrist for that one killing them Mur it's
almost like it's like you kind of get
the green light I think we still run
that question to a couple of them you
know I got other ones other scenarios
but usually they all end up with like
you know can you hide this gun from me
see that okay we that's interesting Yeah
by itself yeah maybe other venue other
avenues to take as well as weapons and
felonies what are we really going to
like what you think maybe that maybe
like that's just a first question that's
maybe coming on a little strong maybe
that's like the third question yeah it
could be the third maybe do they even
want kids could be a question you want
kids right yeah that's okay good that's
a good one yeah do you want kids with me
uh what do you mean maybe that's a
question for them well be weird if
they're like oh thought with you I'm
like what do you want to co-parent to
adopt the child together I got my hands
full um maybe a dog we could co- parent
a dog that's a good way if you do end up
with someone to kind of that's what I'm
going to do if this doesn't work out the
bachelor stuff I'm just going to get a
dog I'm just going to get another dog
and I feel like that'll fill the void of
me just you know sometimes I'm alone at
night and I'm like what am I doing here
yeah just watching space documentaries
falling asleep
yeah space doent did you meet my new My
New Puppy can I have this one
absolutely where's ducky where are you
ducky are you guys selling dogs ducky
where are you ducky right there I don't
want to see the dog unless it's for sale
oh that's a cutie he's absolutely not
for
sale he is our special little boy he's
so cute he's like four months old Yorkie
he's so he's so sweet he's the best
look wow boy boy he's got the best
disposition about everything and he's
he's already doing so good with potty
training where'd you find him um from a
I don't know how actually Lena helped me
find it from a no not at all it was I'll
tell you he was uh he looks 12200 it
wasn't that much 1200 I mean that's a
lot of money for for that's a lot of
money but for I'll give you 25 right
now that's 100% profit yeah you want to
come home with me don't you yeah I'll
tell you what if you take my dog I'm
going to have a proposition for ELA but
you hide this gun for me here let's get
rid of this I love him though he's such
a good boy yeah so
um Dan yeah I heard that you weren't
really I got to click this what the [__]
is this here Dan that I heard that why
did you need to click that because the
thumbnail looked crazy what
the all right all right it just had it
had like 30 million views go ahead sorry
about that little just little
distraction there so I saw a clip you
guys were talking about me doing the
Bachelor and Dan didn't think I was
serious about he didn't think I was
taking it ser I so Dan I more serious
about this than I've ever been about
anything in my
life to uh maybe I did Express something
about that um but you know my biggest
concern is more related to something you
said early on here which is that you
know you guys have a 100% success rate
has um have you looked into that success
rate at all what do you what do you
mean 100% success rate then that's not
even arguable yeah no it is no you're
right Sam and Ian who are still together
them moved across the country they live
together they're in love okay years how
long you guys been together Ian that
sounds like the sound it'll be five
years in November wow wow we're so happy
for them we are well and and and Sam was
and how what was the influence on your
life of meeting
Ian I
mean a lot everything changed for the
better mhm everything changed that's
what I'm scared of everything's going to
change after this series
the better yeah I'm faithful that you
guys will have a good a a good lineup um
now the confusion about the two shows
going on about how I was planning on
doing my own that's how this came about
I said I was going to do a show we were
going to produce it with my own crew and
make it more of like a reality show like
The Bachelor style and we're going to
have like the jokes would be like you
know instead of a rose you get like my
poll like a barber poll you know it's
like a you know stuff like that okay we
were thinking it through but Al that's a
big commitment and I don't know if I
want to show all of my like dates you
know on on camera for the world here's
where here's where my hesitancy is in
that it's a bunch of dudes that are
going to be pouring over a bunch of
women's
resumés and then you're going to be
picking for yourself who you want to go
on a date with I feel the Optics of that
might be weird am I wrong I was trying
not to look at it we started this email
and we just started as a joke and then
the email started blowing up and there's
really good submissions in there so I
might just pass that off to you guys CU
I trust your crew and I can give you
guys that and say it comes down to like
maybe there's like a top three or
something maybe I can spin that into
like a sequel or spin-off or something
but that's just like these are all
options down the line I don't know I
might find the one and just be like all
right this is it you know I don't I
don't need any I might fire my whole
team leave this business yeah go back to
cutting hair smuggling oh cutting hair
yeah got it um that sounds good you told
me that you have like a thousand yeah
applications are date Jeff wick.com um
how does that make you feel that the
you're the subject of so much Amorous
feelings and and uh people really want
to be dating you used to
it you know no I'm just kidding uh it's
weird it's a weird feeling it's a it's a
weird feeling I get the I wear like the
watch too and I get notified from the
emails all day long and it's like oh
[__] this is just like these girls
spending time on this and you know I
just feel bad cuz I want to be nice to
everyone you know have you always had a
a PLL on
[Music]
women go
ahead have I always been I mean yeah
yeah okay yeah I've I've been uh yeah
I've been cool my whole life you've been
cool your whole [__] life and
um uh very good well this is a hunk this
man is used to the attention and so you
better I'm also very sarcastic so don't
take everything I say seriously I but I
was I was cool in high school yeah I
believe it I believe it and have you
ever found that being handsome and
alluring to women has ever been a
hindrance in your
life uh no cuz I've never been like an
[__] and also I got humbled really
badly by that crane so that you know
stopped me from dating for a while cuz
you know I had to relearned my fa you
know my face changed so hurt my
confidence talking to women even this
right now I'm I'm thinking about you
know you're thinking about how your eye
look looking at my eye oh really yeah I
think I think about that I'm looking in
your eye that's what I would be doing
anyway yeah but it's insecurities you
know look I'm an open book and I'm going
to be that on the show I'm going to let
them know my insecurities train [__]
smashed him right in his head and little
mo mozzarella that's such a good sound B
grab wait wait who said that little mo
mozzarella little mo you don't know
little mo you'd love him I know MZ King
the MZ King it's another it's aut
another mozzarella flavored influencer
damn that was a good grab Zach he's the
best yeah we got it all we got it all
someone's firing over here and so when
you go out is it are you are women
constantly throwing themselves at you do
you have to make an effort I don't go
out much but no not I mean
not as much anymore and I never know the
difference if it's like somebody knows
me from online so I I can't really trust
to make you insecure whether you're say
can I can I trust that this person is
interested in me or they or are they
interested in perhaps getting exposure
from me that's a yeah that's definitely
a thing but I've been in situations
where I I would hang out with a girl for
like a whole date like a whole night and
they say oh I don't even know you I
don't know any of your stuff and then
they slip up and they say something like
they'll mention somebody I shot with or
oh that's lame why would they LI or
something and I'm like yo what the [__]
follow Tana on Instagram and like you're
telling me you so I don't know I'm a
little hesitant with certain situations
but I trust that you'll vet these girls
absolutely and I'll tell you what the
ladies um are going to be pouring over
the applicants there going to be comb
through by women looking for uh uh true
intentioned lovely women right Sam I
mean you're spearheading the the search
uh there is going to be like a short
little Google Form application and then
you'll be able to attach the video in
the application and you also have to
provide some proof of age so your ID 25
you can blur out sensitive information
but we have to be able to see your age
we went with 25 and above but there
could be exceptions if it's like
somebody that's like a star athlete or
something you know you that you
down more yeah how far down would you go
if there some 24y old girls are probably
more mature than I am okay you know so
it depends I wouldn't want to shut it
off completely there but also I was
going to joke around with you and say
like I want a 18-year-old virgin only
but I didn't know how I know you're not
like that I didn't know how you would
take that in a text text I I know how
you that's not that's not Jeff go ahead
what what about like a 45 50-year-old I
would go I said I would go up to what' I
say 80 yeah 80 we got no limit on the
top side pretty much yeah oh so you want
to go down to
24 I wouldn't go over 80 because then
it's like you know how much time do you
even have left with the person you know
we were just talking about that right
and on the other side 23 or 23 or
24 yeah that's about you're 34 yeah okay
I think that's okay as of a couple weeks
ago so I mean 23 you're a fully
actualized person right should we do 24
that's not my goal I'm just saying I
wouldn't want to exclude somebody that's
like okay say like a like an Olympic
high jumper or something let's say let's
say
24 yeah yeah and somebody that unless
you're an Olympian unless you're an
Olympian then we're
flexible fair right yeah yeah okay now
what is it about the Olympian that
you're willing to uh make exception I
want an athletic son I want to be the
coach of my kids uh baseball team or
whatever it is track team I want to be
involved in that child's life you know
and you think if you if you are able to
reproduce with the star athlete it'll
help my chances this kid will be a this
kid will be a a real athlete yeah
interesting I want that kid training
martial arts straight out the womb
karate baby my son's a karate master
yeah that's great my 4-year-old you
should see him throw punches man that's
great even if they don't have to use it
it just builds confidence I agree yeah
yeah actually the stuff they do is
really like just fun and silly and cute
they do like obstacle courses and stuff
but it's really cool it's fun he loves
it no striking yet I don't think so yeah
okay they do like ninja courses just
it's just fun silly stuff nice yeah yeah
so look we're the same you me yeah I was
that was my top number one as
athlete yeah no well he was a [__]
gangster yeah she is she was in the
military she's very tall too yeah that's
I mean look I trust you guys you'll find
me a nice a nice one so um when are we
doing this when are we we're launching
this on Valentine's Day right the
submissions okay so here's how it works
yeah that's what I was going to ask okay
so everybody is going to send an
application along with a video Cody
please don't poke in like like that
you're going to freak out the oh Cody's
here I was like who that who is
that hey Cody he got the address now
he's here you guys just roll everywhere
together huh yeah I needed to make sure
you guys weren't setting me up over here
you
know [__] s wraps me while I'm here
he just comes up and rocks me live
that's what people do now that's like
what live streaming is you just get them
on a live stream and you punch them in
the face and then that's how you blow up
online now is that right I thought
that's what you guys were going to do
today AB [__] shck me not with Cody
here I would never exactly that's why I
brought
him so here how it works we get the
application with a video so we see first
of all is the application good and then
we check the video what she like and so
once we make a short list of applicants
with video then we bring you in what do
you now are down to like 20 uh yeah what
do you think Sam I think 20 is good yeah
something like bachor has like
35 and it all stays here in the studio
it doesn't go out into dates outside of
here cuz I only watched the one that you
sent me and it was all here you're just
doing interviews on the show we won't
make you do anything you're not
comfortable with traditionally we have
not filmed anyone on a date I mean
that's I thought that's what the point
of the show is you know we can do that
I'd love to do that I just so far
everybody told me no you're not doing
that what who told you this
Ian Ian I haven't even talked to Ian at
all about this well Ian kind of no it's
cuz the show has failed both times
before it got to that part that's yeah
that's not like I said there's some
details might here hold the phone hold
the phone you guys are trying to derail
this and I don't appreciate it and also
you're telling you're defaming your own
show okay let's be real two successes
one was Sam and Ian the other one which
is more controversial but you can't deny
the love that they have was Moses and
Trisha who are now on their second baby
yeah produced two two new lives into the
world mhm cuz of your show yes that's
incredible techn technically correct
that's technically
[Applause]
correct I mean lost uh I'm not going to
get too uh person whatever that's how
life works you know yeah so um how
Bachelor works there was so here's what
happened the first season Ian there's a
rule you cannot talk to them outside of
the of the platform of the show I'm so
committed to this even any girls that I
was slightly talking to like maybe
dating a little bit cut them all off
they don't even know why they're all
pissed off at me not that there was a
lot there was maybe like two that I was
like kind of like talking to a little
but you can tell them you don't have to
just ghost them well I was kind of like
look the show's kind of like [__]
you know just for entertainment purposes
but that's what they say on the uh
Bachelor too they're significant other
yeah and then they have to watch me fall
in love with someone else that's the
thing they never expect it but love
comes I know and it comes when you're
not looking for it I we are looking
we're very much looking for it in this
case every time I've ever found a a
girlfriend someone I dated it was always
just random I wasn't like I need a
girlfriend let me go out to this
nightclub or something why is it that
you're how many um serious relationships
have you been in two okay how long were
they three years uh was longest in one
year one year and and what happened if I
may ask if you're comfortable why did
those relationship sh end uh the one
year I went to jail and she cheated on
me when I was in jail but I was supposed
to go to jail for life so you were in
jail for how long uh 4 months didn't you
get off on a weird like yeah I got off
fluke it wasn't a fluke it was they what
they did was illegal it was illegal
search and seizure so okay okay so the
case got thrown out otherwise you'd be
doing life uh they were that's what they
charge you with they charge you they
they always say like the biggest like
charges to scare you and then your
lawyer comes in and like look I'm going
to get you down to eight years and then
it's like oh thank you life though for
selling drugs what a joke of a system I
know right but so okay so she was like
he's going to jail for at least a really
long time so okay but like it was only a
few months and in that time she cheated
on me with my best friend's brother who
was visiting in town cuz this is when I
lived in Miami so yeah that one hurt so
when you got out of jail relatively soon
was there was there some kind of
Reckoning
there pay a visit no no I think Cody was
in jail at that time too but um I uh
when I got out she was there and I was
just so happy just to you know I haven't
seen sun in in four months you know so I
just felt so good to have the sun hit my
skin and then my friend his French he
pulled me aside he's like my my friend
she's no good no and I'm like what the
[__] you talking about and then he told
me what happened and he show he showed
me a picture yeah they waited for me to
get out which is great cuz if they let
me know when I was in jail I would it
would have crushed me you know just
agonizing there in prison so you didn't
know that she cheated on you you thought
you guys were still together when you
okay yeah but then when I got out and
then I found out I was like I'm out
peace and she was like trying to talk
about it she was trying to get back with
you yeah and I was like yo K like look
I'm I'm going to walk away please don't
follow me and that was the end of it
that must have been painful though yeah
but I got my freedom back so it was like
I I had to lose something but I also
gained something very it's hard to look
negative when you get so much of your
life back unexpectedly yeah so if you're
ever going to get cheated on that was a
good time to find out yeah yeah that's
interesting and what about the
three-year one and also me going to jail
like that could be a question for the
girls like what happens if I end up
doing a long prison sentence will you
stay with me in that time will you be my
pen pal will you come do conjugal visits
maybe you know that's what if they say
no they're like it depends how long well
hold on but hold on their honesty has
got to be Valiant in sense that how long
you going to jail
for Depends the crime 10 years 15 years
you know what I
mean she's got to stand by that whole
time there's no statue limitations for
murder so I I mean that's something I
would want to avoid you know um so
you're saying you have killed someone
you just haven't been charged for it yet
they haven't found the body you can't
like weed you can't sell weed anymore
because it's you know decriminalized
it's the government makes the money on
it and there you can't there's no more
room for us guys to make that money
you're say you're saying you're no the
market for selling drugs is closed yeah
cuz the government stepped in and
started doing it and you're saying you
can't well you can't murder people
because there's no statute of limitation
yeah okay so you're saying you're going
to be like say I go to like b or
something I try to leave they can
extradite you and they'll find you they
will find you yeah they'll find you
they'll [__] if you kill somebody in
America they'll find you there's no
getting away hold on
which country let's find out just to
play Let's see if they be comfortable
living in country Antarctica go there
get to USA get some sort of like here
you go China Indonesia Iran Mongolia
Qatar Saudi Arabia Taiwan Ukraine
Vietnam and most African nations and
most former Soviet States so pretty
interesting options okay where would you
go of all these options
um I guess Saudi Arabia
I don't know I've never been China Cody
just went to the Wall of China is that
right yeah he went by himself just to
visit the Wall of China wow do you get
in any trouble with any of the do you
get in trouble over there I'm pretty
good outside the country does he have a
mic he he's that's that's real
interesting Cody that you traveled by
yourself to China that's interesting
yeah he don't need nothing um it's too
complicated to try to plan trips for
people schedules and just got to do it
on your own what do you think about
China what do you think about the wall
honestly I'm very fond of Asia the
people are very welcoming um there's no
litter on the floor so it's super clean
the food's really good everybody
respectful shows a lot of gratitude is
there a
homeless um I love it he loves the
homeless but it's like it's like
starting over because it's super complex
uh the whole Chinese culture how do you
communicate out there I use Google
Translate and Google Maps to navigate my
way
yeah in this day and age is really cool
so I guess we can open girls outside the
country we can open up the dating show
to All Nations all languages
specifically China Indonesia and Iran
Mongolia Saudi Arabia you need to go
there plan yeah are you comfortable
wearing a full body uh B what is it
called that they wear hijab that yeah
are you comfortable wearing a full hijab
cuz that would be in Saudi Arabia
expected right I think so yeah I'd have
to be respectful of their cult culture
of course all right
exciting so you're not going to be mad
if I end up doing a spin-off show of our
our thing here we could collab on it I
care I just want to do ours first of
course it just I don't want to be
dealing with the same people parallel
that would be that would just be awkward
okay you got any celebrities or anything
in there that you could throw in maybe
like uh who's that girl you had on your
show Pokey man
she's reach out to her okay yeah you
like you like Pokemon man I don't know I
kind of I think so she said nice things
about me on the show oh is that right
yeah Fant you know she's a fan she might
be watching right now she does frequent
okay I can reach out sure I'll reach out
to all the way but it' be nice for
somebody I'm not looking for somebody
that wants to become an influencer or
something like that but if somebody
already has established career and they
understand the sort of flow of work that
we have where our brains are always is
thinking what's a good bit for the show
what what am I going to do tomorrow on
the show and working on this edit or
like what the hell is AB doing you
should be [__] Zach what's where's
the sound always thinking about you know
so it'd be nice to have somebody that
kind of gets what we do for a living
that that that'll be good so but also
it's not just like it doesn't have to
only be that so well we're putting out
the call to the whole world and uh I
think they're going to they're going to
come like like moths to a flame okay and
I don't even I I don't know if uh any of
these people I mentioned have are in
relationship so I don't think she is but
I don't know could be private uh is
there any other influencers that uh you
want to put the call out
to um I mean that one I didn't even
think I was going to say that one right
now but um let me think did she do we
have pokey on
Discord I don't know can you check why
you want me out right now does she have
only fans no she don't she's not that
typee of girl no she doesn't do only
fans or anything yeah I I knew it stupid
question hit the button and you can no
and and the only and would only B only
fans be a
problem probably yeah which is fair I
don't think I could get past things I've
said things in the past like vaping no
vaping but like vaping that's fine like
I could get past that I have problems
myself I'm not perfect you know so I
I'll I'll look past vaping if I find the
one that just has a vaping addiction
okay that's good that you're willing to
compromise on that uh but the only fans
I mean I don't think you have to apolog
it's you know it's a preference and you
know it's totally understandable it's
totally
fine uh I'll just message or see if she
responds Dan I'll be friends with you
know her I'm friends with tons of girls
that have offs I support it but just for
my own significant other that I'm going
to commit my life to I would probably
not want her putting all her stuff out
there for everybody to
see you prefer the hijab shoot me you
know no no no I don't think anyone would
be mad at that you know it's it's to
it's a preference you know some guys are
okay with it some aren't it's not a
value judgment if what they're doing is
right or wrong it's not wrong it's just
a preference okay yeah every time I say
okay on the show it's I feel like okay
we got you again why don't you do more
of those debates why don't you bring
more people on argue with
I'm trying it's hard to find good people
cuz that you know how like my skill like
we're in this business as you know
entertainers but we have a skill like
I'm a barber okay I think you're the
best in the world at debating arguing
arguing
whoa thank you at least in our field you
know Best In The Biz thank you you know
I I enjoy doing those as well we're
we're we're uh actively looking for
people to bring on and when people don't
know what they're getting into like me
or like some like dumb kid and they come
on here and you just [__] smoke them
every argument they have you have autle
for and you just crush him surprising
how many people come on yeah with no
idea I mean the my favorite one I don't
know if you saw it was the Nexium The
Tourette's guy I didn't see it that that
was one of our first ones oh did he fake
he had he says he cured tourettes oh I
had Tourette yeah yeah so I let him on
this whole time for like an hour that I
was a fan of him and nexi him and then I
broke it to him I was like I have tet
and you're a [__] con man damn it was
it was goodan pretty nut it was pretty
nuts that that played out so well have a
good night that's good I like the time
you invested into that yeah it turned
out real good Mastermind [__] Mastermind
the biter all right so
um anyway we'll we'll we'll Whittle it
down to 20 and then we'll bring you in
and we'll do our episode one where you
meet the ladies oh on screen on screen
you'll see the video we'll learn about
them we'll meet the ladies okay and then
the second part is the Colin is that
right Katherine MC Brom is
single bring her in bring her on the
show she deserves better absolutely she
went through hell with that scum are you
willing to adopt kids kids are you
willing to be the dad that stepped up
not the stepdad the dad that stepped up
I I prefer not to but I will if I have
to pokey's watching um Pokey are you
single and apologies for being so
forward but we need to know I should
have never opened my mouth well you know
what it is you know you why don't we
just get to the haircut sure but things
are happening that you can
undo I think we'd be a good a good match
I think so we'd be a [__] power coule
she she's super nice she's super funny
yeah she has she's she's great she's a
professional she's she has she's a boss
you know she's a big ear yeah Al you
should know she has a lot of simps
that's like a known thing right I don't
know anything about not the I'm not
calling you one but the internet culture
around her SN Dan is a Sim no she has
lots of ss there lots of guys that
that's a [__] s lust after her all
right but she's just but that but you're
you have simps too probably yeah that's
unavoidable what are they going to do
come shoot me well that has happened
before come [__] shoot
me there you go we love it and Katherine
mcgroom if you're
watching and I know you are so pokei is
watching on her stream let me pull it up
yeah I'm I'm watching right now I got
you I'll see what she say I'm
embarrassed now man that's okay this is
the beginning she
may okay let's see we're gonna watch
this Butterfinger ad for
Pokey dude the ads on Twitch are so good
it pisses me off like these the dude
they get their CPM is crazy I should
just start posting there my last video
had age restricted down to helled down
to Hill pissed me off because I risked
my life multiple times um here she is
let's see what she's say let's see stay
hidden in a box I'm like that's just
dumb okay every time say okay on the
show I feel like okay why don't you more
those debates why don't you bring more
people on AR them I'm trying it's hard
to find good people oh God she's got the
Stanley
Cup somebody tell there's World at
deting atast
you know eny as
well he just mentioned
me
come more specific than that I will say
though I freaking love I love the H3
community so
much
[Applause]
him
up yeah it turned out real good
Mastermind [__] Mastermind here it comes
anyway he called you a boss is that
later on in the
show po I want would you call the
show it's hard to communicate like this
but tell po how delayed is this [__]
well it's like a double delay yeah and
ours is
ours open my mouth know what it is get
the haircut but things are happening
that you can't undo I think we'd be a
good a good match I think so [__]
power she she's super nice she's super
funny she has
she you know
she's you know she has a
she's she has lot of did I just get
rejected I don't think so maybe she was
say female Sims to I'll tell you that
much you have Sims probably maybe she
just embarrassed or maybe she's saying
she's going to contact
you we love it and cther MC if you're
watching I know you are po watching on
our stream yeah I'm watching right now I
got you all so
so
we for the ads on twit are so good we
caught her all right so she's going to
call in I'm sure of it [__] I'm so
nervous now this could be episode
one oh is it maybe this is it May and
this is the thing I'm here for true love
I don't care about the show is secondary
so if you guys click right now then I'm
we're going to just call it can it yeah
I'll can mine too my this will be the
third time that this has happened but
the but Dan you you're missing the trees
for the forest brother whatever Dan
we'll find the New Concept for a show we
can do on Valentine's Day it doesn't
matter if it's in or outside the
boundaries of the rules of the show the
point is Dan that we've influenced the
world [__] say that we live in so you
were so upset I love both times don't
make me pull the clips well now I'm not
of you berading people okay but now with
hindsight I understand the power that
our show has and and matching people up
have you heard from Pokey no I sent her
a message though
she she I'm I'm [__] she seemed
bashful which is good I think she seemed
bashful did she I think so yeah she
threw up the ending the stream card
which yeah that was like that seems bad
no that's not no that's bashful no I
think it was bashful yeah I don't think
it was a bad thing what do you mean by
bashful she being embarrassed but
flattered
okay kind of right I mean she's
flattered she's embarrassed she's
interested she's playing P World okay
Ethan ducky by the way ducky yeah a good
name ducky do you have any um if you
were to have kids with uh uh your
perfect match do you have any baby names
that you already have I got a list would
you say them now or you keep I'll say
some um well I I wanted to end I was
thinking Outlaw Whit would be cool
because it's but also is that two is
that first name middle name uh no that'd
be first name first name okay like it
ends in W and Whit starts with w that'd
be cool also so out chaos I I want to
name my kid
chaos SI that's probably something to
discuss nice with Pokey yeah those a
good she named her her real name can't
be Pokey man no it's e it's Ean right or
it's it's Ean eain eain she she's down
to do some yeah she's half Moroccan
Moroccan she's half Moroccan wow eain
eain yeah I did 23 and me recently well
my brother did what you turn out to be
100% that [__] n no I uh I came back
66% guess what it is Italian for
Sicilian the
mother the real deal
father talk to
me you know where he falls down dies at
the end in the yive fields that's where
I'm from that's where I was born [__]
well not me my family you you came from
Michael's ashes Phoenix yeah yeah so
this bit that you guys do it's offensive
oh no I've always kidding I I love this
I love this have you heard the term uh
it
alophia no it's a real hate crime people
are are waking up to it I've never heard
that Italians I love the IT people like
Italians I have you know the weatherman
on my show Ryan MH he always calls in
and we get an argument he lied to
everyone in his high school and told
everyone he was Italian when he's 0%
Italian but he went his whole High
School oh that's interesting telling
people that he but why did he drop the I
mean after dedicating all of high school
I think you would keep going with
it well after high school's done you get
a new chance he moved to LA and he was
like you know I'm Dr I'm going to drop
the LIE yeah finally get an opportunity
to drop this livee I see I see that's
funny live the truth I actually uh not
to brag or anything but Ela is 15%
Italian which means my kids are 7 and
12% you're not the only one you're not
the only conations
family yeah we're related somewhere
along the way right I knew it we look so
similar mhm
hairlines you know what it could be
something with the hairline cuz how are
we still going we've been doing YouTube
for these many years dealing with the
stress of this career but it hasn't
affected our hairlines whatsoever you
have a great hairline all the beefs you
had you to all the beefs you had all the
cancellations all the stress the
lawsuits does it manate on in my
hairline I mean my I'm [__] up
mentally and physically but the hairline
has uh it doesn't affect it it's it's
held strong it's impressive it's it's
our DNA that we share she not calling in
I don't think so no she's playing P
world my mic was on mute but Cody said
that games over world [__] swer Cody
said that he lied too in high school my
my mic was on mute when he was talking
you lied about being Italian Cody yeah
because you know you grew up in New York
City there's you're around a bunch of
Italian people so it was the cool thing
to be you know the Italian gangster
movies just it's part of the culture so
what are you you're not Italian um I'm
European so I'm Irish Puerto Rican now
aren't you Puerto Rican and Spain and
then I'm half Puerto Rican okay okay we
love that's cool
yeah that's what they told me I was so
have you done a 23 me see he don't want
his stuff he don't want the government
having his that's smart you honestly
that's not even a bad my I wouldn't do
it but my brother did it and he put on
the thing stew it was his first name and
his last name was pidot so got him and
that pidot stupid idiot got him he pidot
he didn't want to give like cuz they
could find out that you have a history
of cancer in your um what's it called uh
like DNA and then your insurance
companies get involved and they're like
no they're going to we're going to raise
their insurance whatever so he was just
my brother's a nut job he's like I don't
want them raising my health insurance
but he's got but they've got his
DNA yeah just not his name but they
don't know it's his I mean but you I
mean they don't know the DNA they'll
figure it out DNA they'll find like a
cousin that's related and then like
that's how they found the Golden State
killer oh yeah about that it's so crazy
the Golden State killer was like the
most [__] up serial killer in
California history he just he murdered
and awarded like uh so many people and
he would it was like Mega effed up he
would like hog tie the husband and then
rward the wife godamn and um it went on
for like 20 years and he was never
caught and uh people have always been
obsessed with the case and it happened
like 5 or 10 years ago that through um d
DNA testing they were able to sequence
his DNA look in the DNA database and
they found somebody who was like a a
cousin oh yeah or something like that or
second cousin or something and so from
there they they visited that person and
started testing everybody close to them
and they [__] they found out they
found him from his D like his SE and
stuff yeah they found they had a DNA uh
sample from
and all these in front of their husbands
tied that's like A Clockwork Orange you
ever see that movie yeah no it's it is
like that it's [__] up damn and guess
what he was a cop damn retired [__]
cop you hear that Cody can't believe it
what the cops what about them they're
worse they're worse than
us I don't want to get into that we love
the police we love the Poli yeah yeah
yeah I look as them as human beings and
you put them in a position of power and
you know there's good and there's bad
what's the difference between a cop and
a criminal they're both looking to find
drugs I should have been a politician
how about that absolutely I'm in the
wrong business Cody for pre we're
getting those felonies expunged it's not
too late there's a new law they just
passed in California it's the only state
that offers it you can get your felonies
expunged so doesn't matter what it is no
it matters just no murder non qualify
nonviolent crimes and my crimes are only
uh trafficking weed so so those are that
seems spongeable and then what were your
crimes Cody um possession and you don't
have to answer everything you asked you
Cody all right I'm curious if you're
willing to say go down just a probation
violation yeah that's it he's done well
you know California is a prison state
right he's been in and out of jail since
he's 15 he did a year in juvenile when
he was 15 to 16
California they charge $100,000 of
taxpayers Monies to house inmates so are
worth more in prison than on the street
think about that it's [__] not and
Michael Jordan Bill Gates a bunch of
them own private prisons is that right
yeah and the state just run
Gates I got to know if that's true no
it's true Google that they even have
immate firefighters in California look
it up they pay you a dollar an hour to
fight forest fires and SE and you sleep
on the side of the mountain for a Time
cut for
33% did you see the movie they just made
Angelina Jolie it's on Netflix there
she's a firefighter and it's like this
[__] is not believable you got Angelina
Jolie she just looks like a perfect
[__] she was made in a lab and she's
a firefighter with the guys just hanging
out it's like a GI Jane type of thing
yeah but Gates Foundation trust invests
in private prisons
again what the [__]
Bill couldn't you find find another
vertical like okay maybe it makes you a
lot of money but Jesus devel BR look
into software development bill I hear
there's a lot of money there it's a UK
oh it's a UK thing uh well this
particular one I think they they have
Investments all over the world they up
their investment in the UK private
prison group so they're like this is a
great investment let's do more double
down baby yeah it is it's disgusting
Cody 100,000 can you imagine how much
good you think about it the average
person people don't make that much money
not even close the payroll is average
salary you're you you're worth more than
being housed in prison double really
yeah double average salary these days
what like 55,000 there you go something
like that you don't make cut you go to
prison my parents didn't make that it
went it's been going up a lot yeah when
we were younger it was like 30 or
something I think yeah it's been going
up damn I can't believe Pokey dissed me
I know that hurts I don't know if I want
to do this show
anymore we've been stung I just got a
text from someone who was on the actual
Bachelor telling me that they are
interested in
you who uh uh right in Discord who it
was yeah D well I had I had their
permission that I can say who it was
okay go ahead uh jinia oh she's awesome
I never watch the show she's she's
Bachelor um she's Bachelor royalty and
she's a she's a she's a friend of the
show a fan of the show she's watching
Jenia Cruz I'll show you she's been on
before oh she's the one that came by
that yeah she's really yeah she's great
she she has a great reputation on the
show too she's one of these characters
that everybody likes she's never been
like shady or anything yeah and she's
super nice and she likes the show which
is Vibes that's the main thing about her
so there you
go um also uh your guys boy Mike maslac
just uh gifted 10 memberships on the hey
Mike shout out
Mike I like by the way I saw on Twitter
you were like [__] you were tagging
YouTube and [__] you're like [__] you
like the blood's on your hands the
blood's on your hands and then Mike goes
this will help for sure that was funny
yeah I was with him at the time and I
was just snapping out because you know
it sucks when you put a bunch of work
into something and then it just gets
shut down like you know we don't we
don't appreciate you you know [__] you
and it was a risky video though of
course I I figured it was there was a
chance it was going to get hit but also
the message was test your drugs it's
easy to get these strips you could order
them on on you get them for free I told
people where to get them for free that
was the whole message of the video just
make it the normal to test your drugs
you know so if I'm saying it then maybe
some kids in a nightclub over here at
[__] what what is it Bootsy Bell or
one I don't even know anymore I don't go
out but just like maybe they'll be in
the bathroom about to sniff off a key
and like hey did you see Jeff's video
and they pull out a strip and they test
it saves their lives I would save one
life there who knows how many lives that
would save if it was not ad restricted
and not put people sub boxes and people
couldn't see it's not recommended YouTu
essentially has murdered people people
will die and who's the blood on Whose
hands YouTube that's right they're
murderers I stand by it
we're this is our this is where we work
and we just do [__] like this what to
say they're murderers yeah it's probably
not what they going to do they don't
care they're too big to but it is true
they they have killed people and they
will kill
again
yeah so but I I'll say this about Jeff
and we'll move on to the
haircut you seem to me from every
impression I've got to be a a real
gentleman you don't go out you don't
date a lot you don't [__] you don't have
to sleep with a lot of women you don't
slee around you seem to be a guy that
appreciates a good solid relationship
based on trust and understanding okay
and I and I think and that's how I see I
think you you're a gentleman like that
yeah the thing I worry about is that I'm
I'm too much of a gentleman that when I
find the one I'll be so obsessed that I
will devote my life to her and making
sure she's happy all the time and I will
slack on my career and then these people
that watch us will miss out there you
guys you hear that his only fear is
being too in love with yeah he's too
good of a
guy I share that fear my friend
um okay his biggest flaw is he's too
good of a guy yeah all right so um let's
do this low tapered fade bro all right
let's thanks for coming by the way to do
this yeah of course can I ask a question
real quick about the video were you guys
using the ray band glasses in no the ray
B Ben glasses only record for a minute
so I had to get like these other ones
off teu and they had a big blinking
light on the side so I'm walking into
the cartel uh place and the guy catches
the glasses he's like camera camera and
I'm like no no Bluetooth is music and
like they were like not having it they
saw the [__] these glass that's why I
was curious you mentioned the blinking
light so I thought maybe they're the ray
bands oh that's funny no no yeah the ray
bands only had a minute we had we were
recording for like four hours that night
all over I the real spy she you probably
need to get some like uh certification
to buy or something e cuz I know there's
real spy [__] they don't have light we
could have put tape over the red light
like just black tape and it would have
been fine but Kyle brought blue tape so
like light blue tape that's why I
thought it was the ray bands as well
because I know they have a safety thing
built in where if you cover it they
won't record if you try to cover the
light yeah yeah they're pretty but I
found a trick once I was getting caught
I just put them on my shirt and nobody
looked at the glasses on the shirt all
right I'm going to go to the bathroom
and then I'll be right back and uh I'll
set up get
[Applause]
ready all right okay we got to start
talking because it's going to be added
to the dead
air check the what oh the donation tab
okay let's look at some
donos uh somebody donated 10 bucks and
said uh on ccav triller released their
S1 on the SEC website you can scroll
through it and see his employment
agreement and see that he has family on
the board and some of the deals that is
interesting I'll look through that
allegedly thank you Eddie uh no not
allegedly huh not allegedly oh you know
no this is the this is their official
filing to go public on the stock market
but you and I haven't read that that
commenter has oh I see right this
commenter come on that's why I
just it's a good call good uh somebody
donated $10 said can you still apply for
the bachelor it the applications haven't
started so yes I guess well make
we make it very clear on all social
medias where to go vot and just for the
handful of you that have been sending
your applications to me
personally that is not the place to send
them they will be immediately
deleted uh with peace and love yes
please do not send any applications or
videos to my email yet there will be a
dedicated email do that not entered if
you are have sent it already right
uh Tony said uh donated 20 bucks it said
Ethan I don't pay five bucks a month for
exclusive content I pay for your
personal information as long as they cut
that out it should be allowed PS any
update about uh getting on the
unscripted podcast what was
that um was that the one that kavanau
went on I believe so yes right I don't
know if there's been an update with that
I'll ask Olivia when she gets
back she reached out they're they're
they're afraid they're cowards they're
cowards over there at the unscripted
podcast uh Sebastian Chavez said yo
Ethan I was in hity
of what what is this Sebastian one let
me see I was in the hitti of an epic hit
and run this happened in the part of
Texas that g okay I was in the middle of
an epic hit and run probably right
they're like actively chasing another
car or something this happened in part
of that gave off major Sundown Town
Vibes if I am missed the extortion
deadline then I can I get a birthday
sound bite
20 yes you can you can get a birthday
sound bite for that for that I'll give
you that I feel like I'm having a stroke
are are they 20 or 21 they're seemingly
20 it's in parenthesis it says 20 so
that was very confusing yeah I hope
you're okay Sebastian I hope you don't
yeah I hope you're not in a an active
car chase right now yeah okay here you
go Sebastian I 20 you there you go 20
going to end up in a body cam video
uh let's see uh JJ hey therapist intern
here and also diagnosed with OCD there's
a type of OCD called existential OCD
involves Obsession obssessive thoughts
about mortality I recommend the book
time and the Art of Living okay okay The
Art of
Living um I recommend the
Bible God you only read the Bible one
book one God brother hell yeah one life
there's a shout out to love in his uh
mustache The Lorax Army standing back
and standing by back you up must the
mustache is disappearing to tonight what
Cape looks better and what's that what
Cape looks what color would be better uh
probably the black one okay yeah
yeah is gone tonight though is the low
tapered fade is that a difficult
haircut no no it's the first one I
learned when I started cutting hair is a
popular haircut it was the one that was
taken off in Staten Island when I was
like 15 when I started my barber career
okay and hey ducky hi at one point that
was the only haircut I knew how to do
I'm going to move
back okay so this is your longest
running cut now there's a there's a low
tapered fade there's a hi tapered fade
also
right um AB keep it I have a feel
Ducky's going to want to in the
hair yeah the hair is going to get all
over ducky and then Ducky's going to run
it all through your house and your bed
tonight you know your hair get all hairy
and [__] you want something to drink I'm
good you good thanks just
keep he's definitely going to get into
the hair he's trouble so gets into
everything do you want it like poly D
style do you want to let me open let me
see what you mean by that cuz I got
product I could get you that blow out oh
no I don't want I don't want
like I I don't like the poly D look dude
that guy is got like a whole bottle of
gel in his hair bro talking about my boy
like that I didn't you know it's it's
his look but I mean do I want my head to
look like um that's sick Wolverine's
[__] claws no that's sick are you
kidding me that's the best hair in
Hollywood you still tight it with the D
yeah nice sent picture Jeff in situation
did you find me in the situation yeah oh
you did
see
[Music]
why
wait right there oh you're you're
friends with the sitch what's that
about um so when the show moved down to
Miami I went along with them as their
Barber because they're all from Staten
Island I went to high school of Vinnie
and I was Vinnie's barber in high school
so when they moved there I was like [__]
it [__] stat Island I want to get out of
here this is a good excuse so I went
down there was filming the show and I
would ask them questions while I cut
their hair and I was miked up with MTV
and that was like how the barber shop
show started you were on TV they used
your Cuts they they cut most of it but
they left in like like little parts and
this part I was smoking a cigarette in
it and my mom didn't know that I smoke
cigarettes and I was like Mom be on MTV
I was so excited and the first clip she
saw was me smoking a
cigarette they did you dirty they told
it was acting true it was fake okay so
I'm going to give you a taper but it
doesn't have to be spiked like those
Wolverine spikes what do you think well
here let's let's do a Google search here
well what what was the guy singing about
who's heow ninja low ninja taper fade
fade yeah do you like that beard lineup
and everything we could do all that the
beard lineup [__] it wait where did that
image go this is going to be sick this
well my hair is not like that yeah no
it'll look it'll look like that the one
below that has curly hair ha right below
scroll down a little bit on the left
this dude that's not curly hair that's
you on the left you like that that's
curly hey he's got a lot of hair up
there [__] me I want to see the lineup
and everything dude okay here we
go into his Skin's going to have like
red lines you might I guess like this I
don't know you know yeah look at the
yeah the chart on I think that's the one
here you go just so you know uh you know
soed all right the haircut starts from
the back I could start from the front
for dramatic effect if you guys just
[__] it go for it do whatever you want
look you see that Sideburn you want to
come over
here by the way I'll be on Jeff's show
tomorrow we're doing it live right we're
doing it live cuz you wanted to do it
live nice we've never done a live show I
thought you someone told me you do it
live for me members or something I do it
live on patreon but I'm terrified to do
it live on my main YouTube channel do it
live it's good that you're going to be
the first guest for
that um I know you're saying that cuz
you think I'm experienced but I am a
huge liability yeah yeah no I'll be good
want borrow the but Tom in hot water I
can't lose the other one right now it's
okay Ethan can behave himself when he's
trying
to just all that out I'm actually
cutting with a half right now basically
skin but yeah get rid of all that [__]
dude yeah look at all that on the neck
you want to get rid so how much you
charge for a for a cut like this I don't
really do it for money anymore if you
were I used to cut here for $15 right
just a regular Barber
Shop check me out all right so as Jeff's
doing
that let's see what else we got just
remember you're sh the screen off
careful oh let me close
this tell me if Ethan got a love I'm
doing my you should call somebody in and
debate them that'd be sick you got
anyone in mine who wants to go to war
right now call in that would be kind of
iconic to be just getting a
haircut while Mike on the line can we
have Mike call in and talk about you
know well you call him out on things
that he's done in the past
or been involved in just yell at Mike
for being a scammer or something dink
dink he's heard enough about think poor
guy what's the deal with that who knows
how involved he was let's call
him well let's
Okay was that true about what during the
live show that you said Logan
was pissed off uh or was that a gag no
Mike was I was talking to Mike I wasn't
actually talking to Logan I have to talk
to Logan through Mike cuz he's right
he's yeah yeah um but did you see Logan
not Logan Paul got viciously koed
recently oh no he did yeah okay let me
pull that up I he he told me he was
boxing I was real excited for him I
thought he was going to crush it too
it's funny you guys who picked that
Clipper in the thumbnail that's like
some cheap that's Cam that was just the
first one on Google yeah it's cool I
guess so this is what's a good one I can
replace it Andis what is it andice
andice gotcha so our boy took the L huh
damn he was so excited he thought he was
going to have a whole boxing career and
[__] I know he was like I'm going to go
win that then I'm going to go do Misfits
and be like a full here let's see here's
the ending of it he's a nice guy a lot
of
energy yeah he crushed it on the live
show speaking of that what are you
what's your thoughts on Tan's
performance cuz I thought she was
crushing it up there I I thought she was
doing fine like I said this
but when the show ended and I heard that
people were unhappy I it came as a
surprise to me I didn't really uh know
that that was going on yeah look at the
stance you getting the stance you get a
shot of that stance
beautiful so meanwhile wait is this the
fight over already I think it's the
height thing can we boost you up a
little bit can we just have you set oh
it's over already here let's just yeah I
think we could show a bit of
it just just pop yeah it's fine it's
fair use can we get you to just pop up
on this oh [__] sorry
yeah nice Jeff I got a I got a barber
question for you sure why why do you
prefer your clippers over like a baby
list or like a a wall I have baby lifts
you use baby lifts yeah all the
companies send me their stuff so I I try
them all but these are are the ones I
started with so it's what I'm used to
this exact Clipper right here my mom
bought me for my 15th birthday oh wow oh
that'swe I still have it I still use it
to this day held up strong and I use
cords which is like so outdated right
and people are like why are you using
cords like you don't know what you're
doing you're not a real Barber but these
are so much quieter for production and
all you [__] out there all you normies
that are Barbers you don't know [__]
about production so you're saying the
wired one are better yeah look at this I
have I agree totally yeah I have this
one
here that I could
use oh was loud and then what a [__]
production this is now that one sounds
nice the first one you want to listen to
this show no no and you get
this so Jeff I've heard you speaking um
lovingly about your mom a lot is is your
dad uh and uh I I don't know anything
about your Dad yeah my dad's in my
he's he used to beat the [__] out of me
when I was a kid okay that's pretty
rough no I'm kidding I I got to stop
saying that cuz oh yeah you shouldn't
joke about that he uh he was a he was
very involved in my life he like I said
earlier like I want to be the coach of
my kids teams or whatever he coached all
our teams was very involved in all of
our lives he worked nights he was a bus
driver in New York city so yeah he
busted his ass he worked hard for us is
he is he what what is he alive yeah I
don't know why I'm talking about him
he's fine he's still here yeah okay
tired now all right so he so he did not
beat you your dad's watching like okay I
beat you and I'm
dead yeah he did not beat me and he's
alive oh he loved that about him no
actually he beat me a couple times but
it was not like anything worse than what
normal like Spanky G kind of [__] no one
time I was I was I'm the baby of the
family so I did whatever I wanted I
would not listen to my parents orders so
it was like midnight and I was maybe
14 and my parents were like you got to
get home and I was not even answering I
was like I'll do what I want so my dad
he pulls up to me in front of all my
friends and he has a dog leash on him
but he's like whipping it like a belt oh
[__] and he's like you don't want you
want to listen to your mother and he
came out and he threw me on the ground
and start whipping me with a dog leash
it was a belt but it didn't hurt cuz it
was just a dog leash and all my friends
a humiliation yeah it was a humiliation
which is he got me like that's way worse
I'll take a beating like you could beat
the [__] out of me break my arm
humiliate me in front of my friends way
worse so you're like real life Bronx
taale I guess oh yeah the Nero didn't
want him hanging out with the yeah yeah
yeah I guess that's my dad he's the Nero
in a bron tail and he was a bus
driver wow that's a that oh it's that's
a good story knowing that he wasn't
actually hurting you just embarrassing
all my friends were like this is child
abuse okay they thought he was beating
your ass his plan backfired but you know
we talked about did the police ever
visit or some [__] from that huh did he
get in get any questions about that they
probably will now yeah they're coming
back there lock them up statue of
limitation on beating your kid with a
good question uh someone fact checked
that all right let's see what we got
here oh he's got something in
Discord oh I had this saw this photo and
I wanted to know if it was
real
um this is a video of trump that I just
saw on
Twitter why does it say love posted it
oh cuz i s in
what'sapp so is this like is is this a
recent and real
photo I'm going to say I'm going to say
no because he's wearing the presidential
uh windbreaker there I don't think he
can wear that that is it real is the
photo real or Ed that's a presidential
[__] bulls right there brother shut
up cuz that's for sure if that's real
that's for sure like a diaper right
like elephan titis
dude that's a full diaper that man's
ready for a diapy
chain are you looking if this is real um
yeah I'll see if I can find that
photo Dan has been fantastic thank you
thank you
Don is it
okay yeah it's good so in the
meantime
oh why don't we do this why don't we
light burn go burn the
Stanley Cup while we're doing this uh we
could do that we could do that you know
about the Stanley Cups
Jeff no I don't there's those the cups
that keep everything cold
forever oh there was like a viral video
of someone's car that burned and she
came back the next day and there's still
ice in it so we're going to we're going
to light one on fire and
see if the if if it really does or if
that was just a marketing scheme it's a
good idea mhm thank you could we have
Cody light it oh this is the real one I
I think so right it's from this that's
so lame why do people do that there's a
Know Your Meme that I sent if you want
to read about it it's not great a very
flattering photo
but it's definitely not a full diaper
that's so
cute big massive dumps the makeup
situation is so wild
always yeah what a bus kill that was I
like the first picture way more that'd
be nuts that' be sick this would be
like presidential run
ending or the opposite I'd say i' vot
got a diapy no big ball sack I thought
big massive dump ain't no ball sack come
on now come on now boy got big
cylinders all right so are we setting up
the Stanley's yeah all right so out
side we have a video feed we have a
barbecue we have a bunch of
self-lighting
coals that we are going to
ignite get it nice and
toasty let's let's measure the grill
temp we can do that
right if what exactly does it
measure doesn't work on the grill it
doesn't work in the washing machine
doesn't work in the
flask well it's a it's a
thermometer that's the whole point of
the damn
thing all right thank
you
yep a lead situation
though oh you want to talk about your
video uh what the Mexican drug
trafficking yeah
um ducky what's happening did you watch
it I watch bit of I don't watch the
whole thing the second half is crazy
when I go back with Cody cuz the first
time I went down with Mike and I had the
idea but I was just going to like first
person Vlog it and just see what really
went down and then I don't want to if I
watch it they'll
probably look at Cody he looks more
dangerous they us up and then try to
exort us for money saying we're buying
drugs and he's yelling at them nah this
shit's no good so where are you guys in
Tiana yeah oh yeah Tiana is a crazy ass
City this is all spy glasses
$20 $20 sacks
yeah this guy's face the second time but
he's he's not that serious he's not so
that high are you afraid that people can
use this as like a basically a guide on
how to buy drugs in
Tijana mean that's or there's if people
want to find that out there's already
videos that show exactly that I needed
some sort of shock value to get people
to watch and then the message was test
your drugs
you have access to these fentanyl strips
and they're free and I introduced them
to the guy in the website in the
nonprofit that they could get their
strips for free she get you some so you
can uh car no no onion the
[Music]
um [__] the drugs tell me where to get
this those tacos are fire look at this
[__] yo I don't need fenyl I need me
some aada
tacos
mhm
but it was fun I I had a good time and
it wasn't it didn't feel dangerous it's
just the scoring of it you know like we
scored it to be suspenseful I want I can
hear you Dan I wanted people's Palms to
be sweating when they were watching it
so they you were able to buy fent and
all and [__] everything we got China
White heroin we got cocaine we got
that's CRA everything we got B
everything that's crazy it's so easy to
go down to Tiana you get steroids you
get OIC they have o word allegedly yeah
allegedly yeah that's that's interesting
everything that's a hell of a drug to
traffic OIC yeah
uh I know a guy you do you know a dealer
who sells OIC that's awesome I'll talk
to you about it after yeah it's
awesome did he I didn't see nothing I
don't know nothing about
nobody oh that's funny you guys want to
do the controlled
substance you know right uh yeah that's
true it might not be I mean yeah so
that's not a felony probably
not right so you're good Cody oh [__] I
didn't say
that you don't give a
[__] oh
good all right so let's cut to the um AB
the barbecue can you hear AB yes I can
here's a good ab he's outside how's the
grill going is it is it raging no but
it's it's ready to rage you want me to
start it let's let's check the temp in
there uh
okay I just want to know what
temperature the grill is what it's on
it's not on you want me to light it
first and so what's the strategy here uh
AB are we going to stand them up on the
grill or we going to lay them down uh
whatever you whatever you
think we can lay it down I think or it
was standing up in the original video
I'll point out that is
true so let's just stand it can you
close the top it's probably too tall
okay uh putting the lid over it yeah
yeah it's probably too tall I think
that's good enough though if it's
standing under a flame and you can keep
licking it with the with the gas the
starter fluid
hell yeah checking the temperature so
here we go AB good have fun out there AB
thank you let get the fire marshall
involved your car is the closest so if I
accidentally the Fire gets too big it's
all good
you all right what do you think about
that I mean that's a fire now that's a
fire that's a fire that's a fire yes
sure is is lead a good insulator maybe
that's the special recipe M so you want
me to take this time how am I supposed
to do this just put just put it over it
as close as you can without hurting
yourself you okay you have to close the
grill and then there's a thermometer on
the top oh that's a good idea did you
hear that
yeah but it's going to take a second to
get up to
Temp you might kill the fire too
right uh it has it has oxygen coming in
the little holes up here little holes
you could put it in the hole Yeah that's
a good idea sorry ducky okay I'm opening
the app for the thermometer sorry duck
duck okay why don't we throw them on ab
and we can take the temperature as
they're
cooking um no th those are full up with
ice right yes okay Google says uh a
normal Grill is 500 fight 500 yeah
that's a hell of a lot fire
hotter
the washing machine was like
150 yes sir you know what this fire is
not holding as good as I had hoped I'm
put some more fluid why is he wearing
like a [__] Hazmat
mask oh there we go that's
fair it doesn't need more lighter fluid
it does you're not supposed to put
lighter fluid on a active yeah yeah yeah
you are I'm from I know this I learned
this in Deerborne no we're doing yeah
okay we're going to do it ducky I'm
sorry sweetie yeah I think it has to be
laid down or ducky if we want to close
it yeah yeah we don't have to close it
just put it over the fire I don't think
it will close it up and then we got the
Hydro
Flask my my fear is that it's not
getting enough surface
area well you know what I mean so more
more fluid you think like you can lay
down the Hydro Flask can you lay down
the
Stanley the plastic is going to melt
probably it'll melt but it should be
insulated yeah let's lay them
down let's barbecue those
[__] [__] stupid yeah he's
okay there stop with the fluid you don't
need any more fluid I'm a professional I
got it don't worry about it so here you
have scientific experiment I'll say the
hydr flas is getting more direct heat if
you want to maybe you know what I mean
yeah you got to like a steak you got to
move them around a little bit spread the
flame out evenly oh my God yeah I'm not
seeing the tongs down here Daniel tongs
are at it's hard enough to cut am I
moving too
much I what's that Dan more fluid you
said uh it's fixable okay all right I'll
I'll stay still I'll stay just you know
I got you you you have extra like you
know jerks too in there you know and I
got Dan you said more fluid and all the
other stuff hting the show yeah yeah I
got you I'm going to be still it's my
work that's on the line here sure it's
your reputation mhm there's a little
Spritz of uh lighter
fluid now how's the flame distribution
looking AB pretty good yeah pretty good
and the top doesn't seem to be melting
or anything like that
actually uh neither really showing any
signs of melting yeah no so far so good
what you maybe throw the top on there eh
yeah let's let's put let's barbecue
those [__] a little bit more
fluid just for Dan right there no he's
right he's right he's right and
leave the holes open it'll get hotter
with the holes open holes are open no
talking for 10 seconds oh there're the
tong that's no
[Music]
problem all right you good nice line the
[__] up shees looking clean my boy so
take the temp now AB okay put drop the
thermometer and in the
hole that's that's what she said sorry
sorry about that I'm locked in I'm
liking what I'm seeing okay it's going
up 67 75 85 95 100° oh man
106 all we
110 all right just just wait like a
minute otherwise you're just going to be
counting this is the counting podcast
razor blade is now on your
face 130 remember that time you uh made
me call in live
wasn't so funny was it damn look at us
now who's in the hot seat now I'm scared
[__] easy
easy easy
there all right go ahead AB give us the
update it's uh 200° that's heat that's
heat baby that's real heat nice that
heat this is a smart thermometer so I
hope it lasts this is a legit test I
mean how long should we let it cook in
there 10 minutes we said before our
first test yeah well I'm wondering
because you laid it down I I actually
have a suspicion
that that's going to work to our
disadvantage here I think it's going to
start leaking we're seeing a lot of
smoke coming out now a lot of smoke
coming out a lot faster especially with
the top on cuz in the original thing it
was standing up and so any yeah but it
was no but like the whole top part was
exposed to Flame the bottom part is not
that
big you know what I mean I guess we'll
see I guess we'll see well you want to
you want to take a look now yeah take a
look see if it's leaking let's check on
it AB we're opening the lid check you
got that lid that white smoke on the on
those babies are looking good let's get
some
salt perfect you're getting nice grill
marks on that uh Stanley AB yeah I'm
seeing it looks like it's leaking or or
that just maybe from the top yeah the
hydro FL definitely the bottom of it you
can see it's burning but just because
the material around it I'm guessing
doesn't white smoke mean um water on
fire yeah if it looks like look at those
Char lines yeah give a flip those Char
lines wow
gorgeous do we hear the ice that's a 10
yeah I hear the ice you hear the ice wow
I hear the ice okay so which one is
melting the Stanley they're I mean
they're both getting pretty burnt this
one's definitely hydroask is uh
definitely more look at the grill marks
on that's the
puppy eat your heart out Bobby
filet you know what I think it needs is
uh more fluid yeah get in there no AB oh
[__] you just wait what happened stop
doing that no don't stop yes stop that
is very dangerous to
do
fluid dangerous in what world Dan not my
world in in our world I'm trying to get
some workers comp here Dan do you
mind I've seen so many videos of the
flame coming back up well at the bottle
yeah you do a spritz you don't do it for
a long time a fool does it for a long
time okay you know that right AB yeah
yeah yeah you just got to stand further
away
bro yeah AB knows what he's doing it's a
spritz you know fire is looking a little
weak so what are the coals not I think
the water is leaking and dripping onto
the coal if that's the issue we got to
investigate yeah is your bottom vent
open
AB a good
question so you want to C well let's
take a look get them off the grill and
let's see if there's a leak I I think
maybe we need more oxygen I think we
need more
fluid I don't need more fluid please
stop the handle ooh o look at the handle
you guys see that yeah it's melting it's
like gum uh oh wow uhoh so the handle is
melted oh I just saw water squared out
of the top so the top of the Stanley
yeah yeah the top is not doing so good
Stanley but the Hydro Flask looks to me
to be still
uh solid eh uh the top is Sol it's still
yeah and and you hear ice jiggle in both
of
them I do in the hydro
FL Y and I do holy smoke hold up dude um
Shad is suggesting that it might explode
because it's building up that's true
that's a that is true very
cool that's absolutely uh true Chad
thank you for saying that we want to
make sure we don't miss that it's very
cool uh the you know what the hydras uh
potentially the other one the hydr FL
the seal has already been broken on the
Stanley so that will not you know what
likely explode let's absolutely not heat
the hydr flask more because that thing
will explode all right let's take the
hydr flask off I mean if it's safe
around whatever temperature it's at but
it's cold by the way it's not going to
explode if it's cold inside wait it
doesn't make sense that is true it would
explode because of the steam creating
pressure but if it's cold it's not at
risk of
exploding right
I'm I'm just Jessie Pinkman out here
you're Walt so you tell
me so are the coals still going hot I
mean I'm not seeing Flames but well is
the do you see
Embers not
really
okay let's get some fluid on
there yeah it seems like it must have
got wet so let's
keep
I'm being
very AB if it's not
lighting there's no
fire oh it's going light there you
go
beautiful all right let's get the Hydro
Flask and let's just let them cook Slow
Burn no I said that one's fine it's cold
if there's ice inside it's not going to
explode
it's all right I have the protective
gear for my for my eyes
so if it explodes we'll be okay okay
just keep an eye on the coals make sure
they're they're sizzling yeah all right
we we'll cut back to AB
okay I'm happy you had some sort of
other segment going on cuz it's hard to
really focus on the haircut
absolutely do me a
fav
um I guess I'm pretty impressed so [__]
I mean those things were
cooking you
know we need to go throw it in lava or
some [__] is the next test throw it in a
volcano sure let's do that you down
we'll send
AB to an active volcano are there any
active volcano I'll take care of that
I'll take care of that for you well you
can visit some like in Hawaii that have
like active lava flow oh Hawaii there's
active volcanoes there in Hawaii I guess
yeah if you want to send me there I'd be
happy to do the test it just be an
overnight thing yeah okay sure my flight
might get delayed so you know if I miss
a few days work not even a one night
stay go straight it's all work yeah it's
all work round right that's right you
arrive at 7: a.m. you leave at 700 p.m.
with the Boeing issues the flights are
so unpredictable so if I wind up being
gone for a few weeks I hope you'll
understand all right Dan's going to
throw the flask in a volcano
everybody I just booked the flight on
your card okay are you going to get it
out of there nice after reach your arm
down in that lava well we'll have to um
we'll have to put a flame retardant
string on it a chain yeah titanium
that's probably has a unobtanium yeah
that's got a super high burn have you
ever seen the movie The Core with
Hillary
Swank good movie it's not it's not a
good movie I like every movie you you
set him up you know who's in that
though the
tooch Stanley himself that's
right all right
Gucci how we looking back there Jeff
how's how's my hair cooperating coming
out perfect great uh it's a little tough
it's sort of like trying to cut like a a
wild animal like it's yeah it is a lot
of movement and then the movement
probably true is tough eh yeah mostly
cuz you're talking but I get it you're
hosting a show and also you don't really
give a [__] about what the haircut looks
like not not really I care CU this is my
reputation on the line I feel like if
you [__] up the difference won't even
probably be visible to me yeah you know
what I mean yeah you won't notice no but
I'm sure people at home you probably
have a few barbers in your um audience
here [__] [__] on me right now look
I'm not in the shops I'm not cutting
hair every day I get it there's a lot of
better Barbers out there than me don't
say that but Barbers that also host
podcasts show me one of them that does a
better job there's none there's none out
there there's a guy Vic Blends who does
those like all like sentimental videos
where he cuts people's hair we're going
to send and like Cuts homeless people
and they all go viral on Tik Tok oh I
know that guy he's a phony baloney let's
send Cody to pay him a visit oh cutting
homeless people's hair let me stick a
camera in your face homeless man yeah
exactly thanks for the thanks for the
content idiot does he give him money
look at how much of a piece of [__] this
guy looks like now wait till I come in
and do my stuff and I'm going to fix his
life he's going to get off the streets
yeah give me a break you just made him
look not homeless now he can't Panic
which is [__] up because he is
homeless how can you ask people for
money with a fresh hair and nobody's
going to give him money and like if he
goes in looking for a job he probably
you
know he's got to the other things got to
match up you're ruining lives Vic blend
where's he at right there talk to me
you're [__] those homeless people's
lives up
scumbag do you want to talk about the
Michaela
noera what was that what's what's oh AB
there's no flame AB it's just not
necessary anymore if if it if it doesn't
catch on fire when you squirt there's no
[Music]
flame but I feel I can smell the
barbecue you smell that yeah smells nice
lighter fluid should have got some dogs
to throw in there next to
it
nice I just realized my car is kind of
close to that fire getting wor so is
mine yeah about to test a uh a real car
fire on his [__] Stanley yeah just
[__] burn my car up hey ducky you're
so
sweet you're so sweet ducky you're such
a good
boy how do I say her last name Michaela
n I've heard most people say nagera
like so there was a funny drama with uh
our friend of the show Michaela noera
the makeup bad girl yeah some fake
tan debauchery not debauchery not that
some fake tan drama Matthew Stevens is a
tick tocker and owner of Illusion bronze
fake tan company and he had something to
say about Miss Michaela you're so it's
so hard to cut your hair I felt like I
was being
still yeah it's just did you [__] up
again no cuz so what I do is I have like
a a base so if you move your head I stay
with you you know yeah but even with
this trick it's not enough it's still
tough but would you like I can operate
the well you're cut you're cutting on a
curve you know what I mean
yeah cutting on a curve would you like
me to operate the the links and stuff so
you can sit still e sure that'd be great
yeah show me the show me that's we're
almost done oh for only that would
really help right now is like a sedative
if we could like put him to sleep the
ones with
that no I dumped all
those into Tan's pocket no I'm kidding I
dumped them
we I might have exaggerated some of the
video you know like the heroin and stuff
we left all we buried it oh that's good
we didn't bring any of that stuff back
bury it yeah cuz one time I flushed
pills down the toilet yeah and everybody
got mad at me it was like me why cuz I
had surgery and I had a bunch of these
pain meds I wanted to get rid of them so
I showed flushing them down the toilet
and people were like that's going to go
into our oh that is drinking water and
stuff silly a lot of people said it
you're like trying to like you're like I
am not going to be doing drug no do the
drugs get that out of our water yeah
they said you're supposed to dispose of
them properly is that true I feel like
the parts per million on that is could
be so far from I mean it's a matter of
it's not one person doing it isn't a
problem it's millions of people doing it
all over the country all the time it
builds up and it's and I brought a lot
of drugs home from mexic right yeah that
would have an effect so what's the
what's the data on that if you can I'm
curious what's like if there's
yeah there's official
FDA uh
statement you
know uh let's see don't flush medicine
down the drain uh doing so spring these
Pharmaceuticals can pollute our water
and unintentionally expose us to
chemicals in these medication Studies
have found that these medicines flush
down the drink and contaminate our lakes
and streams which can hurt fish and
other Aquatic wildlife and end up in our
drinking water some medications such as
hormones and anti-depressants include
endocine disrupting compounds that
interfere with reproduction and normal
growth of many aquatic species such as
frogs and fish um what website is that
from uh this is from the Minnesota
Pollution Control agency the turn the
freaking frogs game what's the
URL pca. state.mn.us
it's got a gov it's real do you want to
real catchy one no I want to make sure
Dan's not reading like okay how about
the the Los Angeles County sanitation
department gr crystals ralc it's not how
about the LA County sanitation group or
District
yeah do our trash here
La uh it's.org oh we got aor well anyone
can get a you want a.gov website
specifically okay stay still okay let me
work on that
seconds how about the FDA fda.gov I
don't trust them no no good all right
you good that's the ultimate Dan what's
that FDA say you found it there yeah oh
that's
perfect let's see flushing medicines
because some medicine so the FDA says
because some medicines could be
especially harmful to others they have
specific directions to immediately flush
them down the sink or toilet when they
are no longer needed is take do option
is not readily available how will you
know check the lab oh wait they're
specifically talking about some drugs
are okay to flush but I guess it says
here we go flushing drugs in the water
supply some people wonder if it's okay
to flush certain medicines when the
takeback option is not easily
available uh there are concerns about
small levels of drugs that may be found
in the surface water such as rivers and
lakes and in drinking water
supplies that's all it says the FDA and
the US Environmental Protection Agency
take concern of flushing certain
medicines in the environment seriously
still uh oh oh what a Twist this they
say still there have been no signs of
environment Al effects caused by
flushing recommended drugs oh
recommended drugs on wait what okay so
this gets confusing they're saying
certain
drugs you can flush and certain ones you
can't so they're saying the ones that
are recommended to flush it's it's all
good so check your labels people I guess
I don't know would you trust fding drugs
Association yeah these are the flushable
type um this is looking great oh I'm
excited all right show me show me this
drama
Dan show you the drama okay um well you
you you still are leading it's just uh
well I said Matthew stev a Tik tocker
and owner of Illusion bronze fake tan
company if you open his Tik Tok let's
see here this company has 125 different
shades and they send you your best color
match based on your skin tone hair color
and eye color the other day Matthew
posted a Tik Tok exposing Michaela go
ahead let's watch that this one with
13.5 million Michaela's lies have cost
me 10
what that's 2 a right
Dan I'll double check I just clicked it
from his page yeah this is
it, yes I am $10,000 in debt because of
her lies in October I made a video
asking Michaela if there was any way she
would review my small business my
business illusion bronze went viral last
year and in the video to Michaela I just
explained hey there's this multi-million
dollar company who's sort of knocking
off my idea and I could really use your
help if you don't know illusion bronze
is the only custom self tanner mixed
for each individual client based off col
and Rec can you pause it for a sec I
want to make sure AB is not going to get
more U get um strap nled by the Hydro
Flask looking good ab those things are
those things are ready to go
those those may be done so we still
getting the ice jiggle out there
AB wow and can you it's still jiggling
and
then
put holy oh my God is it less or the
same as it
started sounds the same bro and can you
take a temperature of the exterior of
the bottles and temperature of the
grill yeah
AB is inserting the I I don't know how
to get this off though just touch it on
the outside of the bottle you know or
the bottom then I want you inside of me
yeah AB is you probably want to touch
the needle on that's definitely not
going to be the hot part you know
and I mean you just put on the grill see
what's the temp grill that thing too man
what's the fire
temp there you go that's it give it a
squirt for
[Laughter]
sure yeah one more
time hey no just so the just so people
know it's real experiment yeah it's
real it's a real F what's it reading out
there
warning this needle is on fire warning
over
temperature what wow it's a bus kill
that sounds hot wait what the hell how
high does that measure to that's not
even a crazy flame not hot enough for us
that's all I know
huh oh it say it's the last reading is
uh
280° okay so that's a good that's that's
up there that's hot so I think we can
say myth not busted confirmed isn't that
what they did on St yeah the Stanley Cup
did in fact survived the fire and was
still the next day full of ice although
I'll say this the Hydro Flask performed
just as valiantly so I arguably better
because it didn't leak as far as you
could tell true
true look at those man wow
yummy
drink lunch time grilled water so you're
out there on the ground uh AB what's
your impression here of our experiment
today today uh I'm really impressed how
both of them held up to be honest uh the
top of the Stanley didn't do so well but
that's plastic so that was kind of given
uh if you can put the Stanley upside
down on the ground let's see sorry let's
see uh what's the what's the leakage
like I know sorry I don't think you need
those plastic gloves by the way I don't
think that's I would use those I don't
think that's helping wait what why are
you telling him not to use the gloves
the plastic gloves not the oven know
what I
mean like that's like a sanitary thing I
we're worried about like cross
contamination the cross contaminating
the hydr flask with the Stanley you know
what I mean okay so the Stanley is fully
leaking and is that coming from the
straw hole or somewhere else somewhere
else this is from where it was where it
was burned okay okay okay so this thing
is sprungle leak let's test the hydro
FL
that thing
is find and
delivered bro I know what I'm taking to
the war zone well you know the the
Stanley does have the straw hole which
you
know it's a different
design but uh we applaud our these FL
people maybe people are saying that the
plastic gloves if you touch something
they could melt and then melt onto your
skin it's
probably I'm the professional thank you
I got it than okay all right all right
what they I'm not trying to criticize
I'm just saying is concerned about your
little not you not you I'm telling chat
I got you okay all right give him a
squirt of uh fluid a oh my
God
nice you guys are driving me nuts all
right I guess we can call it off we'll
call it a we'll call it a a success eh I
guess so so do we get a Cara yeah what
what exactly is our reward for proving
who said anything about a reward should
I use this it's about the truth you can
keep the cups it's investiga no no no
don't use that
AB don't use it wait why because we had
all we had them inspected recently and
they're all like signed off for i' I'd
rather save them for a time that we
actually need
them okay it's your it's it's your it's
your fire extinguisher my guy all right
let's wrap it up down there ay thank
you we we'll preserve the
extinguisher wow Dan's
name there it is
everybody the Hydro Flask and the
Stanley Cup both prevailed although I'll
will say the Hydro Flask performed more
admirably as it did
not for sure we're back in the barber
shop hello everybody looking good so
I'll say say this I have not I think I'm
still growing my hair out cuz I got a
haircut yeah you take any off the top no
I'm going to style it up I
got we just launched let's go so you're
going to be looking [__] phenomenal
after this I'm feeling
[Music]
it imagine got
a
[Music]
so ninja got a hight tapered fade cuz he
had a lot of bald skin like if you pull
up ninjas Dan that's a good question
maybe Jeff needs to weigh in on this
yeah you want to line this up do you
want to go for like box out yeah let's
go for it it you don't give a [__] about
anything it's I know it's crazy but I
mean let's box it out let's line me up
nice Let's Line me up nice back in 3
days looks like [__] you got another
haircut this is the barber the oldest
trick in the book this is how you force
people to come back every true true I
don't know though you have such a good
natural hairline I'm kind of leaning
towards we leave it that way it'
definitely be a goof it won't look good
it will look silly but we can't mess
with the hairline it's okay the hairline
is Invincible it'll be back all right
whatever you want though you're I'm I'm
pulling your Le touch it
yeah
neither of them can see right now did
you find Ninja's I did it's up on the
screen once you're uh done get lined up
here oh I see I
[Music]
see Jeff
is um on my hairline yeah that's a low
fade but not a taper fade a taper is
just where you tape up just the lower
just like so he does not in fact have a
low taper fade
paper and a fade is different a fade is
like military style like that you can
get a high fade that looks like you're
straight out of the army whoa whoa whoa
wait what are you say are you saying you
can't have a taper and a fade it
simultaneously is this whole thing a lie
it depends in different states different
cities they have different different
terminology okay okay well what would
you call Ninja's cut right there a low
fade it's just a low low fade no taper
low fade no taper so I didn't go around
his ears and skin this out MH you know I
just went with a taper this is w what I
know as a taper though I didn't know
this meme I didn't know I kind of want
it to look like that you want to change
it you cuz it's so gnarly maybe a little
late for that no it's not right it's a
whole another haircut we could do it I
don't care I thought you just I thought
you just I mean he sounds like he cares
we don't have to do it all I'll do this
I'll do this you want this that's kind
of what I wanted okay because it's just
more extreme I didn't I I was following
the meme you know no I I guess I get it
I guess I get it you don't have to do it
you know what I mean it's fine we're
doing it it's kind of on us we should
have shown Jeff the meme before we did
it I suppose did we not that probably
would have made more sense oh we didn't
show that look it's already getting done
yeah okay all right we're on our way I
want it real high cuz it looks so funny
I always thought yeah that's still low I
I can't do real high I'm going to change
the style but when we discussed this in
the beginning I showed you the D photo
that's a low taper okay well I did say I
do not want to look like poly d i was
emphatic about that right I'm just
pushing it on you no no you're leaving
here like poly D
today hold it all right so let's get
into this this
drama okay speak to me Char I start this
video over sure let's start it from
let's go from the top here no Dan can do
it
refresh
Michaela's lies have cost me
$10,000 yes I am $10,000 in debt because
of her lies in October I made a video
asking Michaela if there was any way she
would review my small business my
business illusion bronze went viral last
year and in the video to Michaela I just
explained hey there's this multi-million
dollar company who's sort of knocking
off my idea and I could really use your
help if you don't know illusion bronze
is the only custom self tan mixed for
each individual client based off your
eye color hair color and skin tone I
launched in January this multi-million
dollar brand had a line of four Shades
coming
out after seeing I had gone viral with
my concept this brand put a quiz on
their website asking people for their
eye color hair color and skin tone and
they would suggest one of four colors so
it basically cheapened and simplified my
idea obviously cuz I have 125
customizable colors I tried to convince
myself that it was a coincidence but
there were a few girl
viral from revie myuct were genuine
authentic reviews and this multi-million
dollar brand went them paying them to do
reviews of their brand and mention the
things that were unique about my product
but instead say it about theirs so
imagine my surprise when 4 days after I
asked Michaela if she would review my
small business she reviews the specific
line from the multi-million doll company
who was knocking me off now keep in mind
when I asked her to review my product
line and then she reviewed the
competitor 4 days later their line had
been out for 6 months at this time so I
didn't believe it to be a coincidence
it's not that I was blaming her I didn't
think it was her fault but I thought wow
this company has already gone after the
small influencers who blew up my brand
and paid them they must have seen my
video to Michaela and now paid her too
this video I posted wondering if it was
a coincidence garnered 4 million views
Kayla dm'd me the next morning and said
it it was an absolute coincidence it
would never be my intention to hurt a
small business she said I think I
actually have your Tanner regardless
when I get home I will make my purchase
and try your Tanner ASAP we DM back and
forth for a while she does say I wish
you would have come to me first I was
like uh how so then she gave me her
phone number asked to speak on the phone
we talked for like 20 minutes she was
like my parents are small business
owners they've experienced similar
things I like wow this poor girl like
she's young she's doing the best she can
once she's home she shows me that she
has the product as well as shits all
over my competitor but I'm not going to
blast that and for a second I really
thought like wow maybe this
misunderstanding is turning into a
friendship well in October she told me
she was posting it ASAP and then 2
months passed by I really just had
grieved the idea and moved forward I was
like damn it's unfortunate that she
really is the person that people say she
is I don't think he's mad that he didn't
get a free social post by a massive
makeup crator that's what he's upset
about yeah I guess that's a way you
could character seem like something to
expose over at
all like you
know all right let me let me
follow shall I keep going on this video
yeah yeah let's finish it she
understands that just because I don't
have 15 million followers I do have
almost
72,000 and people tag her in my videos
and ask me about her every single day
now for the past 3 months so one day
when someone was in my live asking me
where Michaela's review was I said guys
just let it go and then people started
going to her page and commenting where's
the illusion bronze review texted me
almost immediately I don't know if you
mentioned me or something somewhere but
I'm getting so so many comments about
trying the Tanner and I'm actually using
it this weekend she says I'll be posting
a video about it tomorrow December 7th
now in the past Michaela made a video
about how she doesn't review Indie
Brands anymore because they can't keep
up with the orders there's been a few
instances where the IND her voice is
something else man like it's wild is
this going to make me look like babby
sounds like a Family Guy [__]
character every girl I went to high
school with for real yeah that's a real
accent it sounds like a Staten Island
accent or something it's supposed to be
Boston but it's
fake F somebody that went to school with
her yeah she faked you have you have
Intel cam I somebody I talked to went to
school with her and said it they can she
sounds normal yeah that's like an
interesting like angle to go I'm just
going to have this crazy
accent okay
Bobby are we getting uh more to what you
were thinking let me see I can't believe
you you tell me a low taper fade you
show me a video of a guy singing about
it you know actually I didn't know nin
had fa the haircut you could have just
showed me the haircut what I like about
ninjas is that it's like down to the
skin like it's so extreme okay yeah like
[__] up all all right I'll [__] it up
see now we went from good but like in a
good way like ninjas no it's it's cool
like I I don't want it to look bad but I
want I want it to look extreme you know
what I mean yeah yeah well this is good
Jeff showed at first a good haircut and
now he's going to [__] it up so we know
what he's capable of this one's still
good I just want to see
Dome I want to see bald
Dome I just can't believe he actually
got a low taper fade and you guys didn't
think to show me the picture of the
haircut you show me the guy singing well
I just didn't know I assumed everyone
was on the same page but I thought it it
was standardized I didn't realize that
there's Regional uh differences between
tapers and fades and low taper Fades
higher Fades yeah I didn't yeah I guess
it was just a big misunderstanding but
look luckily we were able to fix it cuz
if it went the other way you can't put
the hair back on true but since we were
able to go this way slowly it's a good
point we're taking our time here and
it's important it is important um
everything's okay all right go ahead
finish the video Let's see all right
let's keep going cannot handle
the the capacity to fulfill all of those
I was a long-term fan and follower so I
remembered that video and the last thing
that I wanted to do was embarrass myself
my business or her Shopify had kept
offering me a $10,000 loan so when she
told me I'm reviewing this tomorrow I
was like let me take that loan the money
gets deposited within like come
on so give the money
back you already spent it 4 hours and I
spent all $10,000
on product I honestly felt like that day
was Christmas I was so excited I kept
refreshing my Tik Tok wait and he did
this after the this was the second time
that she said that she was going to post
something yeah the first time she said
she was going to post something and it
never happened and then now she said she
was going to post something again and he
immediately took out $10,000 loan I've
Seas I've seen what he says I I get
those on my on my homepage too
I'm just saying if this person already
you it's not that serious it's like a
generic thing that they just it shows up
on
everyone's yeah but I'm just saying the
rationale of taking out alone based off
the word of somebody that's already yeah
flaked on you there's not a contract
you're not paying her yeah I would have
maybe held off one more day feed and
when she finally posted she clearly had
a tan on but it was hideous
talking like Beyond orange and the hands
were a mess they genuinely this this
guy's being a punk H wait
what bro sorry your product sucks she
was wearing my product and it looked
horrible dude she but okay the one of
the biggest makeup influencers in the
world gave you a free ad bro he has like
a conspiracy theory about her tan that
he'll get to and I think she purposely
[__] it up
how my product line Works how she could
turn out looking like that still I tried
to find the least offensive photo of
this tan I could find she looks fine
what do you mean beautiful on pause it
here is my message um is the tan bad I
don't think it's bad I think that yeah
it's there's definitely like a
concentration of like there's an orange
tone but Michaela comes in later and
says like I use a filter why would she
intentionally look bad no I don't I
don't she got dressed up like she you
know what I mean she's you talking about
this picture here on the side yeah he
says I think her tan looks good I think
his tan actually looks bad
right [__] got hot dog T by the way
is my tast did I just start beef maybe a
little bit [__] that was advice bro if I
walk around with a [__] haircut
like why I'm catching not going to work
out you know you are your own
advertisement right thanks Jeff
no he's right he's right all right you
don't even have hair
Dan I was agreeing stay out of this
conver oh okay that's why I don't wear
hats I was wearing hats too much the
[__] New Year's resolution I thought you
were agreeing with
Jeff we love the ball you look beautiful
here is Jesus message below I say I wish
I could have given her tips and talked
to her more about how long to leave it
on for when she and I were on the phone
make sure that my was a rapid read the
mess
yeah uh it says you look so beautiful
Michaela okay so he's lying yeah cuz he
thinks it looks like [__] yeah he said
hideous he hates it so fake being a fake
fake phony fake phony right here I wish
I would have given you some hand
application tips you think she doesn't
know how to put on makeup well it's like
all she does she knows how to put on
makeup bag
sorry we talk about it there's more to
this it's not any more serious more okay
I wish I would have given you uh some
hand application tips but I didn't want
to bombard you with
messages I didn't even ask how dark you
want to be I just told you the dark
rinse time 3 hours I'm an overthinking
perfectionist clearly but I hope you
like it in general heart emoji hand
heart emoji specifically okay it's a
little passive aggressive for sure yeah
what the [__] I mean if I was doing
someone a favor and this is a fat
[__] favor let's be real about it how
much do you think it costs for a brand
to pay her to do an ad like this
hundreds of thousands I'm assuming she's
huge she could probably get a a hund for
sure she could and I'll tell you why
first of all the makeup industry is
probably the vertical with the most
money in it oh that's fire okay right
yeah we got to do the other side yeah it
looks good for stop
hell yeah dude hell yeah it's not this
side this this one I got to get over
here that looks good actually [__]
tapered out
wow looking
good third time to charm let's get
it um as I was saying the makeup
vertical is just overflowing with money
and uh their rates that they get are
going to be a lot High higher that
someone like me gets just like General
entertainment um cuz there's tons of
competition to to get and I suppose it
it her content is focused on like
reviewing product too so like an
endorsement from her means something it
does and it's the same with like people
who make videos on YouTube like
Financial advice videos M or videos
about the stock market and [__] their
CPM rates are like literally 20 times
higher Jesus it's insane the money like
I've seen
making like hundreds of thousands off
like a million or like a very small
amount of views huh was shocking
shocking W that's crazy so she's
definitely hooking her up like insane if
I was her and I was getting these
messages after doing that be like man
what the [__] this guy I hear
you all right should we keep going good
thing I don't do anyone favors right
I'll never encounter that problem how
long to leave it on for when she and I
were on the phone Michaela wanted to
make sure that my tan was a rapid tan
which it is you leave it on 1 hour for
light 2 hours for medium 3 hours for
dark she told me she doesn't like using
tans that you leave on for a long time
but she told me she left on mine for 12
hours so I'm like is that why it turned
out so bad still she tells me she loves
it if you're unaware of this Michaela
usually posts in chronological order so
I'm like if this is my tan why didn't
she post a review video she said she was
posting it today called my mom so upset
I'm like Mom when she posts this video
no one is going to want to buy myself
Tanner like how did it turn out this way
and then my mom said Matt with all the
orders you've had has anybody ever told
you they look orange have you ever seen
a photo of someone who looks orange
after using illusion bronze and I was
like No And then I went back and I
looked at her full body and I realized
she got a spray tan not hold her tan
looks I I'm crazy I must be crazy her
tan looks f it looks natural to me looks
good right
I think with that filter I do I mean
like my eyes do see orange if I'm she's
looking pretty
orange where's it orange on her arm what
do you mean where right here it's like
an ombre of orange a little bit so just
her arm and her elbow area is darker
than okay yeah all right go on when she
said she was posting a review the next
day but she lied to me pretending she
even used it at all like why not just
say I didn't get a chance to use it why
are you saying I slept in it and I love
it just
that she went professional spray
tan and then said it's your dumb [__]
3our product that sounds like a hookup
that's his argument yeah Am I by the way
am is my reaction the general reaction
are people mad at her um people people
aren't taking it super super seriously
people are obviously holding her
accountable for saying that she was
going to post something and didn't and
they're like he's a small business you
have to respect a small business but no
she's not like canel did post yeah she
did post all right go
on three weeks I'm stewing I'm like
where's the review $10,000 worth of
product showed up at my house finally
I'm like listen she doesn't know how
much money I spent so let me just tell
her the situation and that it's
stressing me out and I know she'll make
it right pause if you want to read but
basically I tell her three so I don't
want to sound like a pest or Pyon when
you're not feeling great melty face
emoji I was never planning on following
up about a review at all because like
I've said you don't owe me anything oh
well keep closed right oh that's the end
of the doesn't sound like he actually
believes that yeah but when you texted
me three weeks ago saying that you were
doing it the next day I placed a $10,000
order with my lab bigger than I've ever
done before because I wanted to prepare
I yeah oh my
God so that's made me a little
stressed I'm super sensitive and
understanding when it comes to your
mental health and it should be your
number one one priority always but it if
you manag to muster up the energy for a
New Year's Eve tan or something soon I'd
be super grateful so this dude's like
can I get another free
ad huh this D is crazy and she has like
has she said that
she
foral she you'll see her I wanted to her
interactions with Tim are really nice I
think I she does seem very kind to and
his interactions are super pass here he
finally moved himself I want to see what
he or what the response was oh my god
well the good news is you'll have the
stock when the video is posted I didn't
have time to do the review that day so I
decided to just try it and see what I
thought and then the next hand I'll film
the review when I have more time I
didn't want to rush it and be shitty so
wait a minute wait wa wait wait wa wait
so this video that he's upset about this
is not the review it's the one where
she's wearing the tan so did she do a
review no you'll see her response to
this because she didn't do it after
obviously this video okay so oh he was
waiting for a do review and then he
dropped this oh what a idiot he's
blowing it God he's blowing it big time
[__] [__] happens man you got to roll
with the punches a little bit better
yeah dude you blew it pal you blew it
VI I still don't but just to confirm so
this video that he's upset about where
she looks super orange was his product
even identified in this video she's just
assuming for some reason it's a spray
tan I don't know what's her he's
assuming it's a spray tan in his next
video his followup into this okay you
can watch it yeah I'm into this all
right all right I'm going back no don't
skip what are you what I had gone back I
had gone back I'm getting back to where
we were thank you find the energy to do
a New Year's Eve tan I would really
appreciate it oh my god well the good
news is you'll have to stop when the
video is post she told me she didn't
have time to make a review when she
originally used the product even though
I now know didn't use the product at all
well she did find the time to do a New
Year's Eve tan now I'm going to do my
base I am going to match myself Tana but
for some reason she chose not to review
mine in that moment even knowing there
was $10,000 worth of product sitting in
my home now it's the second week of
January 2 weeks since I've told her
about this and she's gotten another
spray tan so she said she was posting at
ASAP in October the first week of
December she said I'm posting the review
tomorrow 2 weeks ago I told her because
she said that I ordered $10,000 worth of
product and she's had two Tans since
then and not once did it cross her mind
hey I really should post that review
this guy has all this product sitting in
his house because of what I said to him
she doesn't care about me my mental
health my finances my stress but she
expects you going to put all that on her
dummy no she doesn't and she doesn't
need to
man everyone else to care about her
mental health not the only one babe
you're not the only one I'm telling you
guys this now because last night people
were commenting gu sucks yeah he sucks
she don't know you [__] bro for your
Misfortune right Jeff you blew it you
blew it wow this guy
sucks I'm full team Michaela right now
but let's keep watching all right videos
saying I support Matthew's Small
Business Review illusion bronze she
responded no she responded shut up and
she started blocking people I've got 10K
worth of product in my home so if you'd
like to start out your new year with the
only custom tan please visit illusion
bronze and if you're not somebody who
uses self tanner or can't afford it
please follow me that's the biggest
thing that you can do to help I want to
make sure that I am doing what I can to
highlight small businesses this year for
no compensation we need to be helping
each other in 2024 not just
ourselves we got to go follow him
man uh somebody said is he related to
Jake
dittle oh that's good good
oops guy needs to get hit by a
crane
true a crane [__] smashed him right
in his head all right where do we go
from here do we uh her response her
video this one right here I hope she
brings the hammer down all right let's
see what happens let's see what the
response is so that video got a lot of
views 13 and a. half million and and was
the reaction split on that the people
were mad that she said that she was
going to post but obviously a lot of the
feedback was she doesn't owe you a
review so people were never taking this
drama like super duper duper seriously
like Michaela's career was never in
Jeopardy the stakes are relatively low
sure but I mean no I know but this
guy I mean it's his business it matters
to him you know list sure that's
fair he conducted himself poorly yeah I
agree you could argue that he's just
okay go ahead all right let's see what
let's de like Matthew is a really nice
guy I've had good conversations with him
but I find it really unfortunate that he
decided to take this issue to Tik Tok
and fabricate a lie in order to prove a
point am I entirely wrong that I didn't
review the Tana when I said I would yes
did I mention him that I didn't get to
it yes but still nonetheless I should
have reviewed the Tana sooner but to
fabricate a lie that when I told him I
used his Tana he says I lied to him and
used a spray tan I've never gotten a
spray tan in my life I I'd like to brief
with that second of all the reason that
the tan appeared orange is the same
reason I look kind of like really warm
and orangey right now the video has
color Graden on it okay there I was
going to point that out but I didn't
want to I don't know enough about
tanning and what can happen or whatever
but judging can judging the color just
off of photograph is H cuz he's just
he's just going to be collecting my hair
we'll shave him next you could just
scoop him put him in his bed he'll be
happy he's going to get a low taper fit
dude sorry Dan go ahead anyways white
balance is a thing and uh you know it
can definitely specifically orange uh
make your skin tone look much orer if
you're not calibrated correctly okay so
that her excuse here checks out to me
and she she's Le okay if I take the
color Graden off of my video let me show
you what I look like and this was just
in a video of me showing my outfit so if
I did a video using the Tana it wouldn't
have color Graden on it but it was just
a random video so let me take the color
grad and off and show you what I
actually look like this is with the
color grad and off totally different and
yes I have this t on and I'm not
orange you didn't notice the difference
here let me uh kind
of so let me get a video used in the
Tana it wouldn't have color Graden on it
but it was just a random video so let me
take the color Gren off and show you
what I actually look like this is yeah
it's significantly less saturated oh
thanks okay yeah with the color Graden
off totally different and yes I have
this Tana on and I'm not orange at all
and I've never gotten a spray tan and I
didn't lie again I am completely in the
wrong because I should not have told
Matthew oh I'll do it tomorrow when I
when tomorrow came and I couldn't do it
and I did tell him I did tell him I
wasn't able to get to it because I was
in a rush but I was going to get to it I
always get to it it just sometimes takes
a bit anyways he messages me again
around you know New Year's and lets me
know that he had purchased $10,000 units
or $10,000 worth of Tana which I did not
advise him to do that that is a business
decision that he made fact of the matter
is I didn't get to it yet that's it I if
you look at my track record of Tanner
videos the making a Tanner video is
different than me sitting at my beauty
desk I do them like once or twice a year
and I don't tan often at all last G
tanned maybe three four times so I know
that like 4 months has gone by since I
said I would do the review but I just
don't tan a lot and I don't make Tan in
videos a lot he cannot rely on me for
the success of his brand he just can't I
just I don't know what to do in this
situation but I am
sorry it's crazy that he posted that
video while waiting for her to post the
review of his Tanner when she said in
text to him that she loved it she was
way too nice I agree she was very sorry
for what she admitted fault for for for
not posting for not posting it too like
just straight up that was my fault I
mean yes so I don't know what do we rate
that apology as the apology I don't I
mean it it she didn't need to apologize
it wasn't an apology and it shouldn't
have been it's not her fault I'm not
even going to rate it because she's so
[__] right uh these are her I guess
her comments are just
uh a lot of uh people asking about it
well I'm losing my mind that people are
actually supporting this
guy I mean he he he was so manipulative
you're looking just like Paulie let's go
my boy
[Music]
let's go you go a little wow get some of
that good [__] in
there what's the product you want to
plug I'm using just a tiny little bit
where can people get your new products
you get them on Amazon they're all
available on amaz oh you're selling them
through through Amazon we have a website
but the hair oil that I'm about to use
next it's going to [__] blow your
mind oh yeah going to [__] review it
like this guy
Tana so it's exclusive to Amazon I'm
going to make if you don't review it
right now I'm going to make a whole Tik
Tock what's the uh what's the name again
I'll pull it up uh of the products yeah
Jeff's Barber Shop I love the Pomade you
brought it in here I think last time and
I've been using it since I use it all
the time too Jeff thank you guys I
ordered the hair oil and I just got
notified that it just arrived I have one
for you here wait oh yay I only have one
though because my friend's been taking
them from my house so you're cool with
people buying on Amazon is it not better
for you to buy directly or you just sell
it on Amazon it's better to buy directly
I'll make more money on my website but I
just like having it available on Amazon
okay
cool all right check me out dude here it
is it's this stuff right that's the oil
oh that's a lot of oil Jeff is this it
yeah that's it so what is hair oil look
at those reviews baby send the foot
soldiers B those reviews guys they are
great products smells good you can rate
it up to five
stars that's what we sell say yeah
exactly um what is hair oil Jeff so you
know how your hair like looks a little
dead and Frizzy in some spots sure this
is just giving it that healthy it's
basically putting back in the natural
oils that your hair is stripped when you
shampoo you know do you shampoo often uh
every few days yeah so it just takes the
little flyaways away and gives you a
nice healthy shine smell nice and
overall hair health let me get a closeup
of this AB or whoever's got the camera
looking good he I think he wanted to I
can't do that to you I didn't I didn't
whatever
yo check me out right now you
guys okay everyone's going to be posting
this Chad Ethan watch Chad Ethan right
here y'all [__] part of the family
now let me see the other side do it do
it with
360 let me see the back all
right that's clean yeah
Bo I can't wait till my head turns all
gray it's getting I'm getting a couple
but this right here I can't wait for
that time in my life you'll get there
after a few more cancellations what
thank you our people wrong button wrong
button we have an Italian
but what do you think you like it I like
I like it a lot scale 1 to 10 let me see
it again ABY give me some close-ups here
love the the fade looks real nice give
me I don't I like how it look like I
would never cut my high my hair this
high but I like how it looks let me see
the hairline I just slightly touched it
up I didn't want to go into the widow's
peak too much cuz I know you're not
going to keep up with it no I want to go
with a real natural look all my products
you only need a tiny little bit of them
you don't have to glob up this is not
going to you know you have that old gel
that gets all flaky and stuff never have
any of that with any of my products
looks like you're naturally Perfect Look
at that [__] that's a 10 out of 10
that's a perfect haircut I love that all
right let's get this is my favorite part
of the haircut you're going to want to
see this this is satisfying right here
for all you ASMR freaks out there real
close look at this oh yeah don't you
want to just see that oh that last bit
oh yeah I get what you mean that is
satisfying that must feel nice too huh
Ethan
feel feels
fine oh it feels real good doesn't it
look at that one it's a nice I look at
that chunk get that out of there clean
it up it's like watching uh power
washing uh videos they clean the
sidewalk
nice nice I know I got a youthful back
of the Dome uh-huh if you don't show
your face you'd be 10 years younger man
and then this is uh a manscape shaver so
oh I have that same one are you
sponsored by them I was before I lost
all my sponsors did you lose all your
sponsors yeah I took something about Ben
Shapiro happened a couple years ago L
all of them no not all of them but we
did lose a lot well manscape come back
and sponsor him look that's what I'm
saying I'm using it on him there you go
I think they're start they're slowly
maybe thinking about coming back I'm
tight I'm like this with man skap I like
I worked with them a lot in the past
they're good people yeah their stuff
works too you don't snip your nuts no
blood in to
right yeah
baby
[Music]
excellent you
know I was going through a tough time
with my video getting age restricted and
crushed for all my hard work but this
moment right here makes up for all that
wow
nice the joy in your face glad we could
confidence the new found confidence wow
I love it you look like you're 27 years
old
unbelievable check me out dude you're
good unbelievable I'm a good old
boy I'm glad you like it I'm going to go
wash this stuff off my hands so I guess
let's finish the Michaela story and then
we can get and wrap it up cuz it's
getting light where did Michaela where
did my tabs go uh when we people are
defending we watched her response that
that was that so is that it no there's
one more Matthew he comes back then came
back for another round so let's see the
response to the response now Michaela
just posted a response to my Tik Tok I
want to be very clear about why I made
the I took out a quar million doll loan
while waiting for this response in
anticipation of her apologizing Max I
went to every bank and got all the cards
available and maxed them all out and
quicks four airbnbs in the last 24 hours
knowing that this video make
Y video the day before yesterday my
followers were commenting on one of
Michaela's videos about her reviewing
illusion bronze and Michaela made the
decision to respond to them and say
things like no and shut up and proceeded
to block a lot of
people she said things like
no why what she's known for trolling in
the comments hold on hold on what is
wrong with saying no but yeah what's
wrong with saying no about what did she
say like uh what what was the question
it was review illusion Bronx yeah it was
people spamming is those comments like
we were just looking at a moment ago she
said no well good for her I agree good
for her advocate for
yourself you got 2 weeks ago was when I
told Michaela that I had spent $10,000
on on product no Michaela did not tell
me to spend $10,000 on product but her
knowing that I had just spent all that
money on product why is she responding
to people in her comments section saying
things like no and shut up and blocking
that because you're annoying you're
totally I know the answer well also the
timeline he's like rewriting history a
bit he took out the loan was waiting on
her and then he told her about the
loan after he had already got it and
after he was waiting for a while he
wasn't like upfront like hey I'm going
to do 10,000s before is that cool like
like sorry bro what the [__] man you did
something dumb that doesn't entitle you
to anything
except the consequences of your own
actions God I hate this guy all
right that was a beautiful way that you
said that only the consequences of your
own actions thank you so Michaela that
is why I posted that video I really like
Matthew Matthew's a really nice guy had
good with him but I find it really
unfortunate that he decided to take this
issue to Tik Tok and fabricate a lie in
order to prove a
point am I entirely wrong that I didn't
review the Tana when I said I would yes
did I mention to him that I didn't get
to it yes but still nonetheless I should
have reviewed the Tanana sooner but to
fabricate a lie that when I told him I
used his Tana he says I lied to him and
used a spray tan I've never gotten a
spray tan in my life I I'd like to brief
with that if Michaela is saying that she
didn't get a spray tan I'm not going to
double down if I'm wrong I'm wrong and I
apologize for that see I've been
airbrush tanning people for half of my
life and there's something called either
a heavy hand or a light hand when you're
airbrushing and when somebody has a
heavy hand it's usually a bad spray tan
or somebody inexperienced they'll start
out on one part of the arm the higher
part light and then it gets really heavy
as they pull down and if somebody who
spray tanned a lot of people that's what
it appeared like to me but like she said
that's not true second of all the reason
that the tan appeared orange is the I'm
going to double down I'm not going to
argue and then he goes in and explains
how professionally he is able to tell
that he's right that's such [__]
dude this guy
sucks what is wrong with the world where
people watched these and thought he's in
the right like I don't understand the
world we're living in why is this this
Behavior being rewarded God damn I feel
bad for I feel bad for who for him that
he I don't feel bad for him at all man
yo has pokem man called back or anything
any any word for uh let me check if I've
heard back from not my business is done
here I could leave yeah yeah yeah no no
word from Pokey I'm
afraid my dude I'll work on it's this is
what I figured you know this is what I
signed up for the first rejection the
first rejection yeah it hurts it humbles
you at the beginning I've been I've been
humbled enough you get used to
it so Jeff thank you so much that was
awesome of course thanks for having me
and I'll see you tomorrow at 12 yeah you
want to do 12 that's I mean whatever you
want to do a different time 1 maybe sure
1:00 that we didn't know can you update
that Lena uh cuz we don't know how to do
a live show we've never done one before
and we you say you do it live on patreon
isn't the same completely different no
because uh Dan you should know I guess
you have to set up 24 hours in advance
to allow your channel to go live you
don't have to that's just an option no
no no if it's never been enabled at all
yeah oh so we we've never even oh so
you're at that stage I'm I'm terrified
about it we don't have to do a live no
let's do a live let's do it okay it's
about time and who better to start with
than if you guys need who better I I've
done this once tce I can I can help
point you in the right direction if
about anything thank you thank you Dan
thanks Dan yeah I appreciate that I'm
sure Oscar would love that you know we
look up to you guys your crew is solid
what you did what you've done so far and
that show at the end of the year yeah
that was good despite my uh co-host
sabotage you were great you were great
it was fun no problem yes so um tomorrow
at 1 okay and then guys Jeff's
Barbershop let's support
I appreciate that and are you available
to do haircuts I I didn't come here for
that I know you didn't I know you didn't
I'm try appreciate the plug um if
someone wanted a haircut from you
specifically what's the can they do that
they're like you know
premium
uh you know what I mean just you're
better off going to a barber shop at
this point you know like it's hard to
track me down you know then I'm going to
have people like videos me and stuff he
said he was going to cut my hair this
week
yeah yeah yeah just you know you could
get a good haircut go to like a find a
Dominican guy Dominicans are the best
that hair yeah you want a nice lineup
like guy doesn't even speak English
that's the guy you need to be going your
haircut it's a good lead yeah but it was
a pleasure nice to see you
Cody um I love that that relationship
has been ended you know yeah me and Cody
we're dogs now I said we're dogs now uh
Sam was this yeah yeah yeah I know Sam
was this you that you wanted the hair
Royal I'll leave this over here oh nice
on that red hair too that's going to
work go nice here you
go very good
um oh thanks man Cody says I look 10
times younger I should keep it like this
I I don't ever get like real haircuts I
mean
ever yeah it's true he
go but also we're together a lot and I
don't you know yeah you know come I'll
leave that razor blade there that dirty
razor blade got it if you want to give
it away to one of your fans or something
send that out there definitely not be
keep the DNA inh housee I did that to
Hassan when I cut his hair you saved his
DNA I saved all his hair when he had the
long hair and somebody that bought a
Pomade I mailed them his hair how did
you know that they wanted his hair
because on the stream I was like whoever
buys a Pomade right now I'm looking at
all the sales a random guy and I picked
this guy named Bryce and I actually we
actually the hair back from him I mean
Hanan could be on like going on a murder
trial or something soon because R has
got it he could be framed did you ever
hear from Bryce no we justn mailed I
don't know uh oh that hair went
somewhere it's somewhere that DNA went
somewhere Hassan so watch your back
that's right Golden State killer I would
speak an attorney right
away all right let's uh let's push
through
this as your bye Jeff all right bye guys
are you all good thanks man Jeff
everybody it's Jeff Jeff FM it's Jeff
Jeff Jeff Barber stop Jeff everywhere
Jeffrey full name's Jeffrey
nice Jeffrey guys is that an Italian
name
Jeffrey H no my mother named us all
terrible names my sister name Karen her
life is
miserable is she feeling the effects of
the Karen phenomenon oh yeah she she got
in a fight with guy cuz car making fun
of her oh she she got she gets in fights
she does Jitsu yeah oh your sister's a
badass yeah holy [__] Watch Out Who you
calling Karen out
there yeah all right love you guys fam
see you man see you tomorrow see you
dude all right go ahead with the all
right we're almost done like really warm
and orangey right now the video has
color Graden on it so if I take the
color Graden off of my video let me show
you what I look like and this this was
just in a video of me showing my outfit
so if I did a video using the Tana it
wouldn't have color Graden on it but it
was just a random video so let me take
the color Graden off and show you what I
actually look like this is with the
color Graden off totally different and
yes I have this t on and I'm not orange
at all and I've never gotten a spray tan
and I didn't lie again I am completely
in the wrong because I should not have
told Matthew oh I'll do it tomorrow when
I when tomorrow came and I couldn't do
it and I did tell him I did tell him I
wasn't able to get to it because I was
in a rush but I was going to get to it I
always get to it it just sometimes takes
a bit I just want to clarify again when
she told me she was posting it tomorrow
she did not the next day tell me oh I'm
so sorry I was so busy I didn't get to
it she didn't tell me that until 3 weeks
later when I contacted her and said hey
you said you were posting this the next
day I bought all this product then she
said oh I'm sorry I was too busy I
didn't get to it anyways he messages me
again around you know how important you
are like on her day-to-day life do you
know how important you are compared to
everything else like [__] zero you're
at the bottom of the list
dude like what the
[__] he thinks that her whole day and
week and life should be revolving around
this ad for him I'm losing my mind and
let me know that he had purchased 10,000
units or $10,000 worth of Tana which
which I did not advise him to do that
that is a business decision that he made
Michaela did not advise me to do that
and I 100% did that on my own and here
is why I used to review Andie Brands all
the time when I was making those IND
brand review videos you know 90 to 100%
of the time the product would sell out
um there's been a few instances where
the Indie brand cannot handle
the the capacity to fulfill all of those
orders there have been cases
where I sold out a product and the brand
got greedy and sounds like someone else
product back in stock but it wasn't back
in stock and people ordered it and then
waited months to receive it because this
Indie brand was dishonest had people
buying a product that wasn't even in
stock does that video explain to you
guys at all when she texted me on her
own out of the blue a little bit hey I'm
posting a review tomorrow that I would
go and purchase a lot of
products is it's still his dumb ass
fault listen bro I mean I guess I no
because she already said she was going
to review it he she was saying I don't
review these Brands anymore because of
this happened but she already told him
she was going to review it uhhuh so he
could just sell out and Mark it as sold
out he didn't have to risk his ass and
get he took a gamble with that and
there's no guarantee that I mean I guess
it's fairly guaranteed that he would get
some sort of listen bro sales Boost from
her plug but um but yeah I don't know
bro Tak out a loan look at the end of
the day it's your life it's your
business you're the one that's got to
look out for yourself come on man give
me a break true
I'm anti this guy I am anti
Stevens go
ahead I didn't get to it yet that's it
this final part of the video is the only
part that really pissed me off I will
say almost no one in my comment what
part pissed him off oops section was
defending Michaela but the two or three
people said the exact same thing which
she regurgitated he can't rely on her
for the success of his business he
cannot rely on me for the success of his
brand he just can't I just I don't know
what to do in this situation but I am s
my business did very well last year so
then what the [__] the problem if your
business doing so well then what is your
why don't you just shut the [__]
up like I'm sorry I'm team Michaela
bro damn come on am I the only one no I
agree with no no I'm definitely leaning
towards her side of the argument in this
um by the way got some Intel from our
boy Rich Lux oh for real yeah donated
$20 this guy is Mariah K's ex assistant
No Cap he talks about it in other Tik
toks how he's working for Mariah
Carey you want to talk about 911 that's
an interesting tidbit Rich that is an
interesting little tidbit thank you Rich
I wonder why you got fired my God miss
you rich we love you all right there's
like 10 seconds I've worked on for six
or seven years this is just about when
you say you're going to do something
just do it I think it's called Integrity
oh my God I I listen Michaela I'm sorry
you had to deal with this guy and she
was so nice about it honestly she
apologized she said I was wrong she she
didn't really go after him which she
could have you know I would have right
that would have been that would have
been war in my world but she was she was
classy oh [__] yeah dude me and the
boys [__] right
me and the boys I got to start doing a
DJ set I can't believe Jeff was on
Jersey Shore like Jersey Shore at Jason
yeah I didn't know that how
interesting all right are we team Ste
are we team Steven or we team Michaela
we got let's do a poll don't you dare
vote for
Stephen Michaela you're you team
M Michaela I understand that you're
watching this show at least she said
that she
watches are you team Michaela or team
what was the other St Steven whatever
his name is I got to meet Ethan
Klein love theet podcast we love you
team Michaela or team Matthew someone
say Ethan's a hot girl now he doesn't
have time for this [__] should we
give a neither option or you have to
pick a side here you could say neutral
neutral neutal nice good poll yeah
that's a good poll okay all right
everybody let's get the polls in this is
a cap off the day
yep we're going to get to the bottom of
this you know how I feel about
it this [__] guy with his Miracle
spray tan three day 3 hours give me a
break it's it sounds interesting so try
it he got his plug you know what I mean
he's still bitching and he got like a 13
million view video what the hell ducky
just bit me for no
reason he just starts playing and just
nibbled my leg well Michaela is in a
strong lead here and I got to say
neutral is in second place it doesn't
look like Matthew is getting all that
much support although one in 10 audience
members thanks then Matthew 10 is the
anomaly though like you could be like do
you poop in your hand and then eat it
and 10 it's the one and 10 uh doctors
thing like don't recommend brushing
exactly 10% is pretty much nothing and
I'm happy to see that you know what I
mean 10% is
nothing oh she's best friends with James
people are saying well we're not all
perfect are we that is some
[__] apparently that's a problem in
the industry I learned from Tana they're
like scared of him like she or not they
but she was like I just want peace with
him I was like peace with Germany during
the [__] when they're invading Poland
girl use time to pick a
side death to the
Jews easy Ben you can't just throw that
out there
casually I got in trouble for and now
who's saying the crazy [__] now man
right play the whole thing Zach Al Akbar
death to America death to the Jews death
to Israel that that one's good so good
yeah it's so good all right we're at
3:45 let's get the hell out I feel like
I'm not me I mean you're you you're you
you're so
you seems high it seem high on the top
or does it seem in mean that's kind of
it's a high cut I mean you got it when
you cut it all off the sides you know
you're rectangular right now dude you're
hella rectangular vertical when Cody was
sitting next to me he was a really nice
guy by the way but when I was sitting
next to him his bicep was like bigger
than half my body he's huge yeah and I
don't know if I've ever said this on the
show but uh that night whenever he came
by your house um I I went out by your
house to to be on patrol I never told
you and Ela that what yeah me and Lena
Lena was in the car and I made her come
with me is this one of the things that
true or no this is true is true is this
a Michael Jackson's no Lena could Lena
could verify true that's what's up I
mean I didn't know what I was going to
do but looking at him you didn't know
what you were looking at huh do you have
a weapon or something no that's what I'm
saying I didn't have nothing so but I
don't even think my car it was Lena's
old Chevy Volt too so I don't think we
could have done [__] I think the car
wouldn't have hurt him so I'm glad I'm
glad we're all cool now the car would
have
buckled oh that's good [__] you guys
hear
that vigilante y'all really out there
y'all really care about me wow love that
I was out there too with a with a gun I
was I had a firearm I was monitoring
with a drone yep I was there too yeah
there wow you guys are the best I was
but I was there to crash your pool I was
just swimming it was coincidentally he
just was in the neighborhood he wanted
to go for was in theol house th was
there to yeah yeah you guys are the best
Thro was there yeah I didn't see him
while I was walking around with my
firearm you all make jokes but one day
you going to need help and you're going
to look up and it's just going to be me
there yeah yeah I don't care you know I
would have been happy to see you if I
was getting like choked out by Cody for
sure be like choke him so I can
run that's very that's very sweet I took
a life insurance plan out on you I
didn't tell you AB cuz you doing all
this you're doing all the superhero [__]
getting babies at of burning car so I
thought hey it's probably a good bet if
he dies I'm going to get big I'm going
to get big
money by the way that's a joke but I
don't know if we've talked about it but
there's companies doing that and it was
like a huge Scandal yeah they were
taking out life insurance on their
employees not telling them or their
family and then when they died they kept
the money and didn't tell the family or
anything how [__] crazy wild that's
nuts man yeah America baby oh yeah yikes
my boss has a ve a vested interest in me
dying you know it's not a conflict all
right everybody wow it's been a fun
episode thanks everyone for being here
we had a magical fun episode nice to see
Jeff I will be there tomorrow my friend
which I so here's the
thing I will not be doing a members
tomorrow because I'm going to be doing
Jeff's live he was very kind and he he I
asked him to do live so that you know
the people could watch and uh he was
very gracious to uh accommodate so
that's what I'll be doing tomorrow at
1 and uh but next week Thursday we'll be
back see you next Tuesday uh we'll be
back Thursday so are we still calling it
see you next Tuesday Thursday see you
next Thursday okay I'll update the
thumbnail for
yeah and then um Friday we've got we got
something fun on Friday if you look at
the
chat thought we had something fun on
Friday wait there's a BTS on
Friday BTS is here that's
right wow K-pop concert here on the
eight Street
podcast get hyped here it is I mean this
a pretty
good it's a pretty good representation I
mean mine looks clean dude you know I
mean it's better it's better than ninj
way better ninja sucks you want to dye
your hair blue oh my God you get
temporary
spray
ninja blue all right everyone so thanks
to everybody thanks to all members thank
you to all supporters thank you to
everybody that's watching it's all great
love it
all and uh damn condolences to fake
Logan Paul apparently got his ass
beat let me just let me just do this eth
we got to
go
here oh God that didn't look good at all
okay that's all I want to see Kev Kev
website is fixed too by the way it's
back so when I added Cloud flare on it
it redirected to the
www uh version of the website instead of
the non-www
so I've changed that back so it should
slowly gain should in theory gain the
rank back yeah I mean the Brian kavana a
Street podcast Wiki fandom is higher
yeah shout out to Brody pointing that
out I fix so appreciate that all right
everyone we'll see you on tomorrow or
Friday depending on uh it's up to you
guys it's up to you all right see yall
thanks for
[Music]
watching